Äh, ich muss mal gucken, nicht, dass es jetzt abkackt, weil ich die Unity-Media-Leitung rausgewählt habe.
Äh, ne, müsste gehen.
Wunderbar.
Ne, ich hab gestern umgestellt, ich hatte auch Probleme mit Telekom.
Wir haben gestern auch was aufgenommen, ich hab gestern auch mit jemandem was aufgenommen im Discord.
Und da hab ich zwischendrin übelst rumgeleckt.
Über Telekom-Leitung hab ich umgestellt, auf Unity-Media ging.
Ah ja, super.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was die Telekom da macht.
Ja, das ist immer die Frage, ne.
Mal gucken, ob es heute wieder den Disconnect-Sponsor bei T-Lull 3D gibt.
So, Stream läuft.
Ich glaub, wenn du jetzt nochmal DC's oder so, dann können wir demnächst nicht mehr zusammen spielen, ne.
Oh, das ist so schlimm.
Das ist so...
Da merkst du ja mal, was das für ein System ist.
Ja, man muss sagen, insofern ist es ja okay.
Ich mein, du spielst die Carry-Klasse letztendlich.
Und ich mein, du bist nicht umsonst.
An die Top 500.
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Aber es ist trotzdem...
In vielen Bereichen sieht man einfach, es funktioniert nicht.
Diese Delusio-Speedboost-Runde, das war...
Letztendlich, du hast die gekillt, aber das hätte halt sonst nichts funktioniert.
Daran siehst du das halt einfach performance-based.
Das geht nicht in dem Game.
Das klappt nicht.
Das sind halt so Sachen, wo ich mir denke, ne, so kann das ja nicht laufen.
Ja.
Weil im Prinzip hätte ich so viele Runden auch gar nicht carryen können,
wenn du nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwie auf Mercy oder Reinhardt da gewesen wärst.
Ja, oh ja.
Ich kümmere mich nicht daran.
Das wird halt wieder schon oft genug der Fall sein.
Wir machen jetzt...
Ich mach den Titel jetzt mal anders.
Wir machen jetzt nicht Master Plus, sondern wir schreiben jetzt 3600 Plus SR.
Ne, das schreiben wir nicht.
Wir schreiben Master Plus, weil 3600 SR klingt viel zu low.
SR schreibe ich erst ab 4000.
Das machen wir im nächsten Stream.
Wenn wir heute mehr gewinnen als verlieren, machen wir im nächsten Stream...
Ähm...
Raw to Grandmaster.
Schreibe einen Titel.
Dann bin ich halt schon längst drin.
Ja, na gut.
Solange wir noch in den 250er-Range sind, ist alles gut.
Ist mein Chat kaputt oder ist noch keiner da?
Leute, ist jemand da?
Ich gucke jetzt mal in meinem OBS-Chat, ob ich da was sehe, weil in meinem Browser sehe ich nichts.
Ah, doch.
Das Kippenkino ist da.
Moin.
Dann posten wir das jetzt mal.
Auf.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich machen müsste.
Ich müsste jetzt mal alle Games zusammentragen.
So eine richtig fette Win-Loss-Ratio.
Dass ihr mal gucken könnt.
Ja gut, das sieht man auf dem neuen Account ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, ich habe ja nichts gemacht.
Außer, ne, ich habe den Account gemacht, Quickplay gespielt und dann direkt ranked.
Sonst nichts.
Also das müsste man eigentlich auf dem Account ganz gut erkennen.
Der Salatfresser ist auch am Start.
Moin.
Ich glaube irgendwie, das ist noch nicht richtig angelaufen, das Stream.
Twitch zeigt mir vier Zuschauer.
Was definitiv ziemlich wenig ist.
Normalerweise sind es nach so ein paar Minuten immer 30, 40 und geht dann hoch bis an die 100.
Aber jetzt sind es acht.
Ich glaube, das ist noch nicht so richtig.
Jetzt sind es wieder sechs.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Anzeige verpackt ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Hast du deinen Shoutout rausgehauen?
Nee, noch nicht.
Aber normalerweise warte ich immer.
Ich warte immer, bis das Stream läuft und bis das alles funktioniert und gut ist und läuft und tut und chat ein bisschen was los.
Und dann haue ich die Ankündigung noch raus.
Ich glaube, wir müssen noch mal kurz warten.
Da scheint irgendwas nicht zu stimmen.
Vielleicht ist es einfach der...
Das ist halt Freitag.
Das sind die Leute da.
Ja, aber nee, das habe ich ja teilweise unter der Woche um zwölf oder so.
Es gibt immer Leute.
Vielleicht ist der Titel auch einfach doof.
Sogar mit Schreibfehler.
Habe ich?
Ja.
Wo habe ich mich verschrieben?
Gräfig.
Kräftig.
Ja, ich habe mich verschrieben hier.
Moment.
Kräftig.
Ja.
Die Rügenwall der Mühle.
Das schwankt zwischen jetzt sind sechs, dann waren es 13.
Das ist irgendwie kaputt.
Ich würde sagen, wir spielen uns jetzt einfach mal warm.
Und dann gucken wir mal.
Ich poste das jetzt nochmal auf Twitter.
Stream ist live.
Posten wir das Ganze auch gleich noch auf YouTube.
Volle Ladung jetzt.
Gibt es nichts.
So, Face.
Oder aber, es sind gerade so viele Leute in der Overwatch-Kategorie on.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Nee, Deutsch ist quasi gar keiner wirklich on.
Der Kami nicht, der Cyrus nicht, eigentlich gar keiner.
Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Vielleicht ist auch einfach nur die Benachrichtigungssachen auf Twitch kaputt.
So, ich poste nochmal kurz auf YouTube.
Ja, Leute, heute geht es weiter.
Overwatch ranked Road to Grandmaster.
Vielleicht.
Mal gucken.
Gestern hatten wir Flawless-Tag 8 zu 0.
Ging richtig ab.
Ich glaube, das hatte ich noch nie.
8 zu 0.
Also generell ein Tag, wo man nichts verloren hat.
Das kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern, dass ich das irgendwann schon mal hatte.
Du hast was vergessen.
Was denn?
Du musst doch reinschreiben, der Winning-Stream, ja?
Ah, stimmt.
Die Mentalität, die musst du anheben.
Stimmt.
Okay.
Moin, Patrick.
Was los?
Was?
Was stimmt nicht?
Ah.
Ja, Patrick, ich habe den Eindruck, Twitch hat keine Ankündigung verschickt, als ich live gegangen bin,
weil der Stream pendelt gerade bei 8 Zuschauern rum, obwohl es normalerweise immer 40, 50 sind nach ein paar Minuten.
Ich weiß nicht, was da ist.
Gucken wir mal.
Ja, das stimmt, auch Winning-Stream muss den Titel, da hast du recht.
Das ist wieder aber viel zu lang.
Wir machen wieder.
Komm, wir machen das weg.
Wir machen wieder Winning.
Stream.
Hallo, JustSonics.
Heute mal Flawless-Winning-Stream.
Übertreiben es heute mal richtig.
Ist heute die Star Wars-Premiere?
Ja, ich glaube, war das schon?
Nee, das läuft mittlerweile auf jeden Fall.
Vielleicht sind hier alle Kino-Gucken, das könnte echt sein.
Fuck.
Da muss ich auch noch hin.
Heute?
Oder die nächsten Tage?
Ich glaube eher unter der Woche, weil ein Wochenende wird halt voll sein.
Ja, heute ist es wahrscheinlich knackevoll.
Ist wahrscheinlich übertrieben voll.
Ja gut, wenn es da...
Jetzt sind es neun Zuschauer.
The fuck?
Sind die alle Star Wars gucken, oder was?
Ich poste es mal auf YouTube.
Ach komm, wir spielen uns erst mal ein und danach poste ich auf YouTube, dass die Leute auch was ordentliches sehen.
Ich invite dich mal.
Star Wars läuft seit gestern, schreibt einer gerade.
Kommst du an?
Ähm, jup, zack.
Passt Lautstärke so von allem?
An die elf Leute, die gerade da...
Das ist, das ist verbuggt.
Eben waren es 30, dann waren es elf, jetzt sind es wieder 19.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach verbuggt, die Anzeige gerade.
Auf geht's.
Moment, ich wollte den Titel ja noch ändern in Flawless Winning Stream.
Weißt du, wer jetzt, du schreibst rein Flawless, ne?
Und dann das erste Game.
Kann schon sein.
Das fliegt so raus, aber wie?
Max Streamer in 1080p.
Das gibt die Bandbreite leider auf Twitch nicht her.
Also nicht meine Bandbreite, sondern die Bandbreite auf Twitch.
Du kannst nur maximal 6 bis...
Also ich müsste es mal ausprobieren, ob es wirklich...
Ich habe Gerüchte gehört, dass es jetzt bis 6,5 geht.
Allerdings, ähm...
Twitch sagt, 6 Mbit-Bitrate ist Schluss.
Und 6 Mbit reichen nicht für ein schnelles Game und vor allem auch ein recht kontrastreiches Game, so wie Overwatch.
1080p, 60 FPS mit 6 Mbit.
Das ist nicht so.
Das sieht einfach kürzer aus.
Wie hoch bist du mit SR?
Äh, nachdem wir gestern so reingehauen haben, bin ich jetzt 3662.
So, ich queue, okay?
Mhm.
Oh, erst mal einspielen.
Passion, alter, Passion.
Aber, äh, Amazo, das ist ein neuer Account.
Sieht man ja auch hier am Level.
Ähm, die anderen beiden Accounts, die ich habe, habe ich seit Season 3 nicht mehr gespielt.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, komm, scheiß drauf.
Machste einen neuen.
Dann lernst du das Game wieder ein bisschen.
Und mittlerweile klappt es eigentlich wieder ganz gut.
Auch wenn ich teilweise noch sehr, sehr fragwürdige Plays mache.
Übrigens, ich, äh, Eax, ich bin in irgendeiner Overwatch-Fail-Compilation, äh, nee, Overwatch-Win-and-Fail-Compilation gelandet mit einem Clip.
Echt jetzt?
Ja, aber nicht mit dem Shatter, sondern, ähm, wo auf einem Bar-Niveau wir attackt haben, wo ich 5 Leute weggehämmert habe und danach das Game gequittet wurde.
Ähm, kannst du dich noch daran erinnern, wo wir den ersten Punkt übelst schnell eingenommen haben vor ein paar Tagen und danach einer raus ist und das Game abgebrochen wurde?
Das ist da drin.
Was stimmt da?
So, was haben wir denn hier so am, was haben wir denn hier für Leute am Start?
Zeig mal her.
Äh, Mercy-Main?
46 Stunden!
Hoho!
Außer Mercy, sonst nix im Endeffekt hat er.
Skill, Skill A.
Äh, coolgei ist Lucio-Main und...
Und Melkorn ist Hanzo-Gel-Shimada-Main, ist er.
Okay, da ist kein Tank dabei, ich muss mal wieder.
Was will er?
Was, was haben sie im Chat schon wieder für Probleme?
Ähm, ähm, ähm.
Ja, ja, was da los ist.
Hallo, Sergeant Tukz und Muri1904.
Nachdem wir das Waren gespielt haben, poste ich dann auf YouTube die Ankündigung, da wird's wieder voll.
Oder voller.
Oh, die Hände sind übelst kalt.
Ah!
Ich bräuchte, ich bräuchte so, auch diese Wärmepads, die die Pro-Stämme haben.
Weißt du, welches dieser Netzwerksymbole links jetzt, äh, welches Symbol da was bedeutet?
Es gibt ja diesen Kreis mit dem Blitz und dann gibt's diese drei, drei Dinger hintereinander bei den Symbolen.
Also die drei Karten sind Paketverlust.
Okay.
Ich hab meistens den Kreis mit dem Blitz, was auch immer der genau heißt.
Ja, der Netzwerk ist jetzt nur links.
Ich wollt grad Steuerung N machen, so.
Fällt mir nur an.
Das ist vielleicht auch vom Reinhardt nicht so gut.
Bam!
10% klar.
Hook mich!
Geh mal langsam zurück.
Was ist denn los hier hinten?
Die pushen übelst rein.
Hämmern, hämmern.
Bricht, bricht.
Ey, Leute, könnt ihr mal ran?
Fuck.
Mein Schild ist halt übelst kaputt.
Wir haben gar nichts im Highground zu contesten.
Die Mercy.
Die hat schon Ulti.
Kriegt man nicht, ne?
Immer wieder ist es gelaufen.
Ich kann auch ein bisschen Ult-Charge generieren.
Moin Twitchmason.
Hallo KX20.
Und eine Taube ist auch am Start.
Bester Name.
Ich hab gleich, gleich Ulti.
Das war noch ganz gut.
Schön noch mal ein bisschen Damage gemacht.
90% Shatter.
Also wenn ich einen Firestrike treffe, hab ich Ult.
Huge Ult kommt jetzt gleich.
Oh ne, voll in die Saria rein.
Rein!
Saria!
Oh, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
ne, ne!
What the fuck!
Schön geblockt, all.
Ich hab noch keinen Shatter.
1%.
Eish.
Das ist mega unkoordiniert gerade.
Ja.
Ist bloß ein Lushu da rechts auf der Seite.
Auf einmal pushen der andere.
Das geht nicht.
Geht doch nicht.
Aber wir pushen da alle rüber.
Ich treffe auch rüber.
Huge Ulti.
Ja, ich treffe nix.
Ja, ich bin auch noch richtig aufgewärmt.
Ah, jetzt haben wir 40.
Jetzt haben wir 40 Zuschauer.
Jetzt ist anscheinend die Twitch-Anzeige einfach kaputt.
Ikantop, das heißt nicht Gören und so was.
Und Babes und Chicks, das sagt man nicht.
Auf Twitch sagt man Grills.
Das musst du dir merken.
Wenn du öfters auf Twitch spielst und willst dich negativ auffallen...
Fuck, fuck.
Ich bin auch noch drin.
Die Sarah ist fast tot.
Das war ein bisschen sehr overextended von mir.
Und ist gereckt.
Scheiße, Grav.
Fuck.
Krieg auch nix da.
Das ist viel zu viel Heilung doch.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Huge, huge.
Oh, die Tracer ist 100 Points ab.
Die ging übelst ab.
Das machen sie normalerweise.
Auf dem Rack nicht.
Dich rausfokussen, wenn du Mac rufst.
Beziehungsweise das Auto callst.
Äh, ist alles tot?
Nee, sei ja, hängt noch.
Okay, ich komm nochmal mit der Diva ran.
Ja, die killt jetzt halt alles noch, oder was?
Wo ist sie denn?
Nein.
Ist sie tot?
Sind wir wieder da?
Ich bleib mal kurz.
Der Roadhog ist ziemlich low.
Ja, kann man doch vielleicht...
Ja, es wäre ein...
Nice.
Defense-Matrix ist weg.
Nein.
Ich hab's nochmal gematrixed.
Wer ist jetzt da?
Wir haben den Roadhog gleich.
Gleich Ulti.
15 Prozent.
Können wir da jetzt pushen?
Ja.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
Drückt ihn zurück.
Schon wieder 2 CP.
Ja, Leute.
Ja.
Wir suchen halt immer die besten Spielmodi für euch raus.
Dass hier auch ein bisschen Content geboten wird auf dem Stream.
Was ist da rechts los?
Nix.
Die Mercy hat geultet, warum auch immer.
Rechts, rechts, Roadhog.
Nice.
Fuck!
Was hat mich denn hier gebasht?
Roadhog fast tot.
Ich hab wieder Ulti.
Äh, nicht Ulti, Schwachsinn vergessen.
Finde an.
Weiß nicht, kann die Mercy nix fassen, oder?
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Fuck, fuck.
Ich hätte fast wieder Auto am Start gehabt.
Ich glaube, ich muss nächste Runde die huge Mercy-Plays rausholen.
Wäre so Ratscaps wenig.
Und gefühlt auch keine Ulti, aber hätte ich alles gewinnen.
Wird erstmal richtig hart durchgepusht hier.
Ja, 1,51, das geht ja alles noch.
Das geht, das geht.
Das hält sich in Grenzen.
Max, ich find's nice, wie aktiv du im Moment auf YouTube und Twitch bist.
Also, Livestream macht doch übelst Bock.
Max, wie alt bist du? Ich bin 33.
Ähm...
Ich warte mal, was die alle so picken.
Gucken, was dieser Juniore macht.
Gucken, was dieser Unique normalerweise spielt.
Der ist echt nicht übel.
Genji Tracer Main.
Okay, der ist immer so in dem Dreh hier.
Aber ich probier mal, was zu hocken.
Aber ich muss sagen,
das Geile ist, wenn du auf dem Tank bist,
dann ist wenigstens der Spielfluss da.
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Nicht so genau.
Du meinst, dass du vorgeben kannst,
wo es hingeht, oder?
Genau.
Zum Beispiel, wir haben 2 Picks.
Ja, das stimmt. Dann duschst du rein. Ja, das stimmt.
Hast du recht, ja.
Das ist ja auch wichtig.
Das ist ja auch echt wichtig.
Eines der geilsten, roten letzten Streams war,
wo wir beide Tank gespielt haben.
Was haben wir? Winston-Diva-Kombi?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Ne, und einmal Winston-Diva und einmal Reinhardt.
Reinhardt-Diva war es, glaube ich.
Wo wir einfach die ganze Zeit durchgehämmert sind.
Ja.
Moin, xbüffel.
Im Streamtitel fehlt ja nur noch ein Link zum neuesten Video.
Warum?
Wo ist die Trap?
Ich seh sie nicht.
Ich glaub, die ist schon kaputt.
Falls es die überhaupt gab.
Ich glaub, du bist gerade drüber gedreht, oder?
Ne, ich hab sie nicht abgedreht.
You Choke! You Choke! Bashen!
Direkt, direkt.
Nein, lass doch nicht die Mercy retten, ey.
Um die 10 Kilometer.
Wollen wir gleich nochmal platt machen.
Bashen, Alter!
Backbrawling.
Die Mercy ist rechts außen.
Junkrat, komm her.
Bam, Bashen.
Alles musst du selbst machen, ey.
Ich glaub, wir haben zu zweit gerade das komplette Team gekillt.
So ungefähr.
Also, ich geh mal links hoch auf den Highground.
Ja, ich capture mal weiter.
Du musst halt fett rein tanken.
Fett bin ich. Das passt.
Doggo.
Gleich Ulti am Start, 3%.
Wieso kommt der Lusche mit mir mit?
Der soll euch reinbringen. Was macht der denn?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Oh, die Zamsen.
Reinhardt, schön am Start.
Kannst du... oh man, das ist schon voll verkackt.
Ich push jetzt.
Wenigstens Junkdown.
So, jetzt Abmarsch.
Oh, oh, Achtung.
Hock bei dir.
Nice.
Fick dich, Stracer.
Der ist nicht gestorben.
Nein.
Oh man.
2 CP, lol.
Huge, Leute, huge.
Die Attack war wirklich extrem clean, ne?
War richtig gut gemacht.
Ja, aber das war der Winston.
Der hat verkackt.
Der hat ne Bubble gegen den Solo-Tracer geschmissen.
Und dann hat man keinen mehr.
Ich mach ein bisschen Schild kaputt.
Ich fahr wieder rein.
Der versucht mich halt reinzuhocken, Clyde.
Das ist Sack, ein bisschen.
Oh, bin ich im Arsch.
Ah, gebadet.
Der hat gleich wieder Shatter, so wie ich den...
Können wir dann?
Ja, ich bin drinne.
Nein.
Hock links.
Es kommt keiner so richtig rein.
Der Hock ist links.
Leute.
Der Reinhardt hat bestimmt gleich Shatter.
Huge ult.
Was ist hier?
Ey, Mei.
Was kommt da?
2 CP, Alter. 2 CP.
Ja, ohne Witz.
Jetzt fang ich das schon gleich an.
Report this guy. Report this guy.
Immer der gleiche Scheiß, ja.
Ich schändiere auch zu Hock hier.
Das hat echt gut geklappt gegen die.
Also, wenn wir da nen Tank haben?
Ich geh nicht von aus, ja.
Nimm mal Hock und dann guckst du mal.
Ich guck mal, genau.
Ich guck mal, ob einer nimmt.
Nee, das ist doof.
Wir brauchen irgendwas, was die aufhalten kann,
gescheit.
Wobei, komm, wir probieren das mal.
Weil Reinhardt hatte ich das Gefühl,
ich hatte nicht den nötigen Support-Gefühl
das letzte Mal.
Ja, das Problem war, der Highground war halt weg
und wir hatten niemanden, der holen konnte.
Ja.
Gegner haben wir jetzt gerade nicht wieder.
Also, das ist dann...
Wenn du jetzt wischen willst,
dann mach schnell.
Nee, nee, ich bleib jetzt.
Die werden jetzt alle gehuckt, einfach.
Mit sagenhaften 38%, easy.
Ja, Evoli, das ist auch das,
was mir bei 2CP auf den Sack geht.
Um den Punkt einzunehmen, muss man gefühlt
jeden viermal töten.
Das nervt mich, deswegen versteh ich es nicht,
dass manche Pros sagen, es ist der beste Spielmodus.
Aber ich mein, ich denk mir immer,
die wissen es ja besser als ich.
Oh, Mercy!
Super.
Welch ist der erste Fight schon fast verloren jetzt?
Ich bin links auf dem Highground.
Keine hier.
Ist gelaufen.
Die Mercy, ey.
Oh Gott, ey.
Ey, die Aussie ist wieder da.
Huge.
Ist wieder tot.
Ja, da stand die Mercy AFK in der Gegend rum.
Ja, gefühlt.
Ich mein, vom Spawn von der Pharah-Rakete
two-hitten lassen. Also, komm.
Jetzt gibt's Sachen, die müssen doch nicht sein.
Fuck, Hook raus. Hook ist rechts.
Ich geh mal nach dem gucken.
Verrecke.
Danke, Mercy. Wieder mal AFK gewesen.
Gibt's nicht.
Fuck.
Konnt ich nix machen.
Ich switch.
Ich komm mit D.Va drauf.
Äh, McCree ist rechts.
Richtung unseren Spawn.
Nice Bubble. Das war gut.
Sag mal, muss echt alles selbst machen, oder?
Komplett.
Ja, ne Chance zu gewinnen haben wir.
Ja.
Jetzt sollen wir den ersten
Spot so wegballen und so.
Äh, Casino-Kapitalist.
Ja, Ult-Charge.
Wenn du gestunt wirst, während der Ult ist jetzt neu,
seit ein paar Patches.
Ich hab auch nicht aktiv gespielt, als der Patch kam.
Ich hab's auch schon bitter bereut,
manchmal Ult gezündet zu haben, mittlerweile.
Ähm.
Ja.
Ist jetzt so.
Hallo, Käsebrot35.
Ist auch keiner Name.
Lass mich raten,
den hast du bestimmt früher in irgendeinem MMO dir ausgedacht, oder?
Das find ich, das liest sich
wie so ein typischer MMO-Name,
wenn man damals quasi trollen wollte, so.
Wie nenn ich jetzt meinen MMO-Charakter?
Käsebrot35.
Damals in MMOs
haben die Leute ja noch versucht, so so so
so Roleplay-Namen zu nehmen.
Richtig sentimentale Musik
im Background hier.
Das ist eigentlich ein Chill-Step-Relaxing-Stream.
Das hört sich eher so nach
Biblethumb-Stream gerade an.
Pass auf, die werden jetzt runtergeworfen auf der linken Seite.
Von irgendwas.
Symmetra.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich bin noch nicht vorne.
Ich hab zu lang rum
gebatet im Spawn.
Oh, knapp.
Wut, meine Flashbring ist einfach verschwunden.
Geil.
Können wir reinpushen, irgendwie?
Alter, ich treff dich nicht.
Ja, rechts, der Hawk.
Und ein Turret.
Also, Schild hat er net viel.
Er hat mich rechtsklickt.
Mercy, du könntest mich jetzt übrigens retzen.
Ne, ne, da pushen wir jetzt net rein.
Ich bin halt schon drinne.
Wir brauchen Pushpower,
sonst geht's doch nicht vorwärts.
Was brauchen wir?
Pushpower. Jemand, der reingeht und YOLO macht.
Wir verlieren das Game sonst.
Das Popen bringt halt nix.
Das ist halt nur Ultimate-Fate.
Bist du wieder da?
Ja.
Ja, Winston. Okay, Winston ist drinnen.
Super.
Oh, Mann.
Gibt's net.
Wo sind denn alle hin?
Okay, ich switch mal auf Reinhard.
Der hat schon wieder Ulti.
Ich fass es net.
Ist der Vayne der neue Mercy?
Stehst da, kannst dich nicht moven,
aber McCree kann mit Ulti dich anchargen.
Sehr geil.
Wir haben beide auf den gleichen McCree-Chancen.
Zwar ein bisschen unlucky, dass er nicht rechtzeitig down gegangen ist.
Aber sind ein paar verreckt.
Also, wenn wir uns jetzt beeilen...
Schon wieder fahren die einmal.
Ich mach Ulti.
Was?
Macht ihn weg.
Der Roadhog muss weg.
Der geht hoch, rechte Seite hoch.
Ja, ich bin auch oben.
Ich brauch hier unten Hilfe gegen den Reinhard.
Nein. Fuck.
Weggechargt.
Ich bin geretzt.
Jetzt geht's los.
Noch einen.
Haben die einen TP?
Ja, die haben einen TP.
Komm, vielleicht kriegen wir das schnell.
Also, Earthshatter ist raus.
Okay, nice.
Earthshatter hat 20%, Gegner hat keinen mehr.
Du musst rein.
Push, push, push.
Easy.
Die sind nicht auf den Punkt gegangen.
Die haben alle im Punkt da drüben rumgestanden
und debated er.
Die haben nix gemacht.
Ja, pass auf.
Gleich reckt er mich beim
in Mech einsteigen.
Ach nee, ich bin.
Ich bin doch nicht deeper.
Easy.
Es ist nicht so, dass wir noch mehr DPS-Leute hatten oder so, ne?
Jetzt nicht.
Too easy.
Nee, nicht too easy.
Das war doch gar nicht so einfach.
Du kannst mal Punkte angucken, was es da gibt.
Ja.
Danach, warte mal kurz, zwei, drei Minuten.
Max, wieso lässt du deine FPS zweimal anzeigen?
Gute Frage.
23.
Ich hab jetzt nicht,
ich hab nicht geguckt, wie viel es gab.
Leute, habt ihr das gesehen?
Ich kann im Stream gucken.
Ich stream-snipe mich jetzt selbst.
Fuck, zu spät. War's schon.
Ich glaub 20 Punkte oder sowas.
Leute, habt ihr das gesehen?
Wie viel hat es gegeben?
Bis gleich.
Ja, warum lasse ich meine FPS zweimal anzeigen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ja, ich lasse es einmal in-game anzeigen
und jetzt einmal von Shadowplay.
Wobei ich das Shadowplay ausschalten könnte.
Soll ich das ausschalten?
Ja, komm, ich schalte es aus.
Ich schalte die zweiten FPS mal aus.
Geht das überhaupt mittlerweile?
FPS-Counter.
Off.
Ist jetzt weg? Jetzt ist es weg.
Und 20 Punkte gab's. Dankeschön.
Es war recht solides Roadhog-Play.
Fand ich jetzt.
Die Hooks haben ein bisschen schlecht gesessen.
Vor allem auf die kleinen Targets.
Und manchmal habe ich auch ein bisschen bescheuert gestanden.
Und mit Reinhardt
muss ich auf jeden Fall
noch gucken.
Ich muss mehr den Charge einbauen.
Also das, wann Ult-Charge gesammelt wird
mit Hämmern und so, das finde ich, das klappt mittlerweile ganz gut.
Shield-Baiten, Hooks-Baiten,
Earthshatter-Baiten
geht auch halbwegs.
Was ich nicht
richtig das richtige Gefühl
bei Reinhardt für habe und das richtige Timing
bei Reinhardt für habe, ist der Charge.
Vor allem werde ich viel zu oft gebaited
von gegnerischen Reinhards, die mich wegchargen.
Das darf eigentlich nicht sein.
Normalerweise
counter-chargst du dann, wenn du so quasi
wenn du gegenüberstehst Reinhardt und beide Reinhards denken
jetzt wird gecharged oder du hast noch ein bisschen Zeit
und siehst den Gegner Reinhardt chargen, dann chargst du auch.
Dann sind beide Reinhards kurz gestunt.
Kommst du da? Ja, das kommt morgen.
Ich poste jetzt mal auf YouTube, dass ich
am Start bin.
Aber muss sagen, bis jetzt ist Flawless Winning
Stream ist vollkommen richtig.
Weil wir haben schon Win-Loss
immerhin 1 zu 0.
Und um
nicht zu vergessen
2CP 0.
So, was poste ich denn jetzt mal auf YouTube?
Was poste ich denn jetzt mal?
Bin Twitch
Stream live.
Wir übertreiben es mal
auf YouTube in der Ankündigung.
Overwatch Road to Grandmaster.
Ich schreibe jetzt rein.
Road to Grandmaster.
So.
Solange der Eax weg ist, ich guck jetzt nochmal
den Chat durch, ob ich irgendwas überlesen hab.
Max, warum spielst du alle deine
Spiele auf Englisch? Hat mehrere Gründe. Erstens ist
die Sprachaufgabe meistens besser.
Bei Overwatch finde ich es
schade, dass man es nicht auf Heldenbasis
machen kann. Zum Beispiel hätte ich gerne
die deutsche Mercy in der englischen
Spielversion. Weil ich es einfach geil
finde, dass die deutsche Mercy Schweizerdeutsch spricht.
Die englische, also die Sprecherin
in der englischen Version, ist ja auch eine deutsche
glaube ich, Lucy
Lucy irgendwas, hab vergessen
wie sie heißt.
Die macht das auch gut, aber ich finde
die deutsche Mercy Sprecherin
ist irgendwie nice.
Ist besser mit Schweizerdeutsch.
Und ansonsten spiele ich die Spiele auf Englisch
einfach, weil es viel einfacher ist
im Internet Sachen zu dem Game zu finden,
wenn man die englischen Begriffe kennt.
Ich meine, such mal nach
Overwatch Earthshatter, findest du sofort was.
Such mal nach Overwatch,
wie auch immer das Ding in der deutschen
Version heißt, du wirst wahrscheinlich nicht so
gute Sachen finden. Und man kann sich
viel besser austauschen mit Leuten,
da wenn man ranked spielt,
die Kommunikation ja auch auf Englisch stattfindet.
Was übrigens eine der Sachen ist,
wo Korea
als auch
NA-Ladder schon
finde ich einen ziemlichen Vorteil hat, was Kommunikation
angeht. So, wenn man das so beobachtet,
ist mein Eindruck, die EU-Ladder
ist das unkommunikativste im Ladder
im Ranked, was es gibt.
Aber ich meine, man muss sich auch nicht wundern.
Ich meine, hier spielen Leute
mit acht bis zehn
verschiedenen Sprachen, ja, quasi von
Russisch bis Italienisch, Spanisch,
Französisch, Deutsch, Englisch,
Polnisch, ist
alles dabei in der EU-Ladder.
Und dementsprechend haben die Leute
ein bisschen Probleme dabei.
In NA ist es nicht so das Ding,
die meisten da reden Englisch.
Bis auf ein paar Kanadier,
die Französisch reden.
Franzosen halt.
Und
die Koreaner haben es auch recht einfach,
die reden halt koreanisch.
Easy.
Bloß wir in der EU haben halt das Problem.
Und wir können ja auch wohl schlecht eine eigene Ladder
für jedes Land machen.
Dazu haben wir einfach zu viele Länder,
die zu klein sind.
Wenn die ganze Bevölkerung
von Deutschland Overwatch spielen würde, dann
würde man auch eine Deutschland-Ladder machen.
So, wieder da.
Kannst queue.
Ich muss jetzt gleich mal in die Highlights gucken.
Wo stehen die Dinger überhaupt nochmal?
Okay, ich queue.
Highlights, wo gibt es denn die Dinger überhaupt?
Ich gucke mir das normalerweise nie an. Hier.
Highlights Roadhog Volskaya.
Da gucken wir jetzt mal, was es da
für geile Highlights gibt.
Die meisten sind die Highlights,
die das Game sich erdenkt, was die Highlights sind.
Gar nicht die wirklichen Highlights aus dem Game.
Ich gucke mir das mal an.
Und man sieht,
wie ich in Reinhardt bashe.
Schön über euch drüberblase
und Ulti gedrückt habe.
Naja, gut.
Lohnt sich Overwatch
noch?
Also, bei noch zu sprechen von Overwatch
ist vielleicht ein bisschen
übertrieben, weil Overwatch ist jetzt
eigentlich allzu lange draußen.
So eineinhalb Jahre oder so, oder?
Was meinst du? Hast du das im Kopf ungefähr, Erx?
Dann kam das raus im März
letztes Jahr.
Es ist einmal so ungefähr eineinhalb Jahre.
Ein bisschen mehr.
Also Overwatch ist noch relativ neu.
Overwatch hat sich auch verdammt oft verkauft.
Und es spielen auch auf jeden Fall noch
genug Leute auf unserem Rank.
Du hast auch nicht jedes Match die gleichen Leute
und sowas selbst, wenn du ungefähr gleich queuest.
Aber
mich würden mal die echten Spielzahlen
interessieren, weil ich meine, verkaufte Einheiten
und Leute, die ranked spielen
ist ja schon was anderes.
Also im Quickplay, als ich hier meinen neuen Account
hochgelevelt hab,
hatte ich echt das Gefühl, dass
das gesamte Quickplay mittlerweile aus Smurfs
besteht. Alle unter Level 25.
Und spielen viel besser, als
ein Rang Fünfer oder so
spielen würde.
Yoshi fragt
Max, was hältst du von Fortnite?
Ich hab's nie probiert.
Ey, von allen Battle Royale
Spielen gefällt mir das noch so rein
vom Sehen am besten. Pupke habe ich noch nicht.
Ich fand's jetzt nicht
wirklich schlecht oder so.
Es hat sich halt einfach nur unfertig angefühlt.
Vielleicht ist es besser geworden mit der Wüsten-Map
jetzt.
Hast du die mal gespielt?
Das Thema hatten wir vor kurzem schon.
Echt? Wisst ihr mal?
Ja gut, ich bin mittlerweile alt.
Was haben wir da gesagt?
Taugt die?
Wie gesagt, zehn Minuten
habe ich gespielt. Es hat so schlimm geleckt,
dass reinstalliert.
Also die Performance von Pupke ist anscheinend immer noch
absolut Weltklasse.
So wie man das nicht anders erwartet ist.
Äh, anders erwarten würde von dem Game.
Es kam jetzt erst vor kurzem die Xbox-weise
und daraus, ne? Die läuft mit 20 FPS.
Oh!
Die haben doch groß die Werbetrommel gerührt.
Ey, jetzt für Xbox.
Oh, ich kann mal wieder Lucio spielen.
Yeah!
Ähm.
Knautschen.
Weiß nicht, wie man es richtig ausspricht.
Ja, das siehst du mal,
was das schon wieder abgeht, ey.
Ui! Touch me!
Nein!
Lock mal, äh, Dings ein, Reinhard.
Also ich denke mit Solo-Support kann das
auch ein bisschen besser werden.
Äh, Control Center ist das mit der Halle
in der Mitte, mit diesem runden Ding in der Mitte,
wo man schön mit Lucio kreiseln kann, ne?
Jaja, genau das.
Ähm.
Ne, ich habe noch keinen der neuen Skins,
weil das ist ja ein recht neuer Account,
da habe ich noch nicht so viele Lootboxen
gekriegt jetzt.
Warum spielst du Smurf-Account?
Ähm.
Es sieht so aus, aber es ist kein Smurf
im eigentlichen Sinne.
Ein Smurf ist für mich jemand, der quasi, keine Ahnung,
Master, Grandmaster gerankt ist und jetzt einfach mal
ein bisschen die Noobs bashen will auf niedrigerem Rang.
Ich habe es seit Season 3 nicht mehr gespielt
und laut internem Matchmaking
von Blizzard
ist es ja so, dass ich immer noch Master, Grandmaster
Games gerankt werde mit meinem Main-Account.
Obwohl ich es seit Season 3 nicht gespielt habe
und das wollte ich einfach nicht.
Deswegen habe ich mir einen neuen Account gemacht.
Oh, Shield-Spam ist real.
Der Shield-Spam ist real.
Busted.
Rekt.
Krass, ey.
Okay, ähm, ich...
Nein, Reinhard funktioniert nicht
gegen das gerade.
Ja, es wird halt schlimmer, wenn du weg sitzt.
Meinst du, es wird noch schlimmer?
Jaja, da müssen die drei Leute da...
Die D.Va ist auch noch weg.
Da müssen wir uns jetzt eigentlich schnappen.
Pass auf, hier liegt eine Falle.
Meine Fresse, ey, geht da mal einer?
Please, Leute, please.
Da können wir nicht lang.
Wir gehen jetzt einfach auf einen Spot
und stellen uns dahin
in die Ecke und lassen die Gegner zu uns kommen.
Das sind die Prost-Trats.
Bam, geht doch.
Ich brauche Heal übrigens, fällt mir da so.
Heal, please.
Junkrat ist noch links.
Unser Genji ist gut.
Nein, ich nehm's zurück.
Ich nehm's zurück.
Toll.
D.Va ist aus Macross.
Ja, super, Res.
Schild geht weg.
Oh, ich schlafe auch noch.
Alter!
Nee, nee, nee, das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Die fisten uns richtig.
Also, noch sieht's ja in Ordnung aus.
Ja.
Ich hab gleich Shatter.
Wir haben so einen krassen Hanzo-Dude
am Start.
Sticky, sticky, sticky, ich brauch Heal.
So, Shatter ist am Start.
Ich geh jetzt einfach
auf den Spot drauf.
Gut.
Please, follow up.
Super Charme, ja, Leute.
Die haben mich ja gefühlt
drei Kilometer in Luft.
Tracer ist auf dem Punkt hinter dir.
Ja, wenn die Messie nicht reißen kann.
Achtung, kommt von oben.
Ja.
Rekt.
Oh, jetzt gehen sie ab.
Okay.
Ich geh mit vor.
Junkrat, Junkrat, Spot, Spot.
Junkrat.
Guck mal, ob da noch was kommt jetzt.
Da ist Tracer noch dran.
Okay, ging doch.
Wow, Hanzo sein erster Kill, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, der hat uns gecarried, der Hanzo.
Der Hanzo hat das so gemacht,
der wollte einfach nicht, dass wir sehen,
dass wir gerade so hart von ihm gecarried werden.
Deswegen hat er die Gegner immer nur low geschossen,
bis auf ein Leben und hat uns die finishen lassen,
weil die beste Eigenschaften
eines Hanzo-Mains ist einfach Bescheidenheit.
So sind sie alle.
So sind sie.
Richtige Hanzo-Mains sind einfach
die bescheidensten Leute, die es gibt.
Die killen nicht selbst,
die lassen dich killen, obwohl sie die Arbeit machen.
Ähm.
Ich bin gerade mal auf Diva.
Also ich hoffe, dass die Leute was treffen,
sonst ist...
Lass links lang gehen, nicht über die Brücke,
weil wir können nur schwimmen.
Ich hoffe, dass der hier mit rein hat,
dass mich da irgendwas runterschmeißt.
Also auf der rechten Seite.
Kommst du?
Ich bin da, ich bin nicht so schnell.
Ich laufe schon so schnell,
wie es geht.
Oh oh.
Ja, schon den Maker verloren.
Heal please, heal please.
Ist ja ein richtig guter Tripple-Stack.
Ich hab die Ana.
Help.
The fuck?
Was sind denn alle?
Alle down.
Ja, genau, versuch einfach mal
ein bisschen zu delayen.
Ich muss selber runter.
Die Pharah, die kickt mich runter,
wenn ich da jetzt nicht aufpass.
Die ist schon da, die ist schon da.
Ist da Korkastenschloss raus?
Okay, jetzt, jetzt,
jetzt ist sie nicht oben.
The fuck?
Please, Leute,
killt was. Jetzt machen wir's.
Facepalm.
Jetzt geh ich auf off-tank,
ich hab nichts mehr gekillt.
Facepalm.
Die...
Och Gott!
Was ist das?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ich hab Shatter am Start.
Ich hab...
Leute, warum hampeln wir hier rum?
Wir können doch einfach warten.
Du musst zurückgehen.
Lass links lang.
Okay.
Ich hab auch Shatter.
Ich hab Shatter.
Okay, die haben kein Schild.
Ich bin da.
Nein!
Ah!
Puh!
Shatter wasted.
Lol.
Leute, das gefällt euch, ne?
Das findet ihr geil.
Ich versuch noch irgendwas zu hämmern.
Scatter!
Wohohoho!
Fett umgeultet.
Da ist er.
Ausrufezeichen rank.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
So was könnte ich mal einführen.
3680?
Oder so ist er.
Was ist denn das hier?
Ach, das mit links und rechts runter.
Ne, ne, ne.
Da spiel ich keinen Router.
Wollen wir...
Wollen wir D.Va Winston spielen?
Ja, können wir auch machen.
Allerdings solo hier.
Ach, fuck.
Soll ich...
Ich kann Dings spielen.
Soll ich Lucio spielen?
Winston, Winston.
Ne, wenn wir keinen Tank haben, dann ist das halt alles wieder für den Arsch, ey.
Kick Serino, North Serino...
Warte.
Die Mercy stirbt halt direkt schon, wenn sie aus dem Spawn rausläuft, so.
Die gehen Onspot.
Ich geh auch Onspot.
Pharah fast tot.
Nice, ist weg.
Ey!
Help!
Das ist aber nicht alles.
Da muss halt ein bisschen Druck auf die Gegner sein noch.
Aber das können wir gut. Das packen wir, das packen wir.
Winnable.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Brautok.
D.Va und Adam links.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Alter, Leute!
Gibt's doch nicht.
Ein Mord-Pogchamp.
Hello.
Bist du in der Mitte?
Bist du da?
Baby D.Va, haha.
Baby Rage.
Ey!
Moment, wo bin ich jetzt gerade hängen geblieben?
Ich komm oben.
Die Hälfte ist von innen.
Kein Schild mehr.
Fast alle, ja.
Ganz schön viele, ganz schön viele.
Vorsicht, Tracer.
Jetzt den McCree wegbrechen.
Scatter.
Oh Gott.
Oh Gott, ey, mercy.
Scatter.
Oh!
Oh, wo kommt denn der?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, der hat mich hardcore gereckt.
Pass auf, von Main kommt ein Winston.
M1-Simulator.
Ich bin da.
Das gibt's nicht.
Ich bin klar wieder da.
Ich bin gerade rausgehüpft und gleich verreckt.
Nice! Easy win, easy clap.
Meine Güte, ey, das ist so anstrengend.
Wenn du bloß einen im Team hast,
dann hast du den Kack gepickt.
Jetzt überleg dir mal, wie anstrengend das alles ist.
Ich weiß nicht, was hast du überlegt?
Du hast ja gestern wieder selbst gemerkt,
wenn du alleine spielst.
Die Chill-Musik ist mir da gerade zu chillig.
Ich muss da mal irgendwas anderes anmachen.
So was.
Moin, Raffi.
Ja, noch 152 Punkte
und dann ist GM angesagt, ne?
Ja, ich habe jetzt 2.700 neu.
Ganz cool.
Max,
hast du den Skandal um Dr. Disrespect mitbekommen?
Nein, ich verfolge ihn nicht.
Erkst, hast du den mitbekommen?
Du guckst das ja öfters.
Ja, ab und zu gucke ich, aber in der letzten Zeit nicht.
Was denn, Blackfire?
Was gibt's denn für einen Skandal um Dr. Disrespect?
Äh,
Z-Pro,
ich mache wahrscheinlich eins, ja,
aber das muss ordentlich vorbereitet sein,
deswegen kann es ein bisschen dauern.
Darf ich mal wieder,
vielleicht darf ich ja mal
anderen spielen oder so.
Ich muss da aber schnell einloggen,
damit die Leute ein bisschen...
Haben wir Mercy-Mains? Mal schauen.
Nope.
Ich weiß, wer Mercy spielen darf.
Du kannst auch Lucian spielen,
also wenn von denen auch eine Mercy nimmt.
Moira.
Komm, ich nehme Mercy, scheiß drauf.
Huge-Mercy-Plays.
Komm, jetzt wieder.
Bin ich ja schon mittlerweile bekannt hier für.
Vorhin hat jemand geschrieben,
er kommt nur ins Stream wegen Mercy-Plays.
Haha.
Hahaha.
Hallo Karottkuren.
Gegner schon mal Diva.
Blackfire sagt, Dr. Disrespect
hat im Stream
erzählt, dass er seine Frau betrogen hat.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie ernst man das bei ihm nehmen kann.
Wie gesagt, ich verfolge das nicht,
aber was ich am Rande gesehen habe,
ist auch noch sehr viel Getrolle dabei, oder?
Ist das ernst zu nehmen, ja?
Erinnert mich an die 8-Inches-Geschichte
mit, äh, Dings, wie hieß er?
Caffrey.
8-Inches.
Oh, hier ist ein Genji oben.
Ja.
Damage-Boost?
Der, der kommt von hinten, klar, der Genji.
Ah, fuck, Kanäle.
Hinter, hinter uns ist er.
Oh.
Ich bin, ich bin, ich bin auf dir drauf.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ich muss abhauen, ich muss abhauen.
Ich kann nicht zurück.
Jetzt komme ich wieder vor.
Genji ist auf
mir drauf.
Alter, ist das...
Der Reinhard pusht Sneaky durch.
Alter, das gibt's doch nicht.
Vorne war alles safe und jetzt ist auf einmal hinter uns
alles zusammengebrochen, lol.
Reinhard ist am pushen.
Ich muss zurücklaufen.
Keine Zeit.
Ja, Reinhard, du needest kein Healing.
Wenn du Healing needen würdest, dann würdest du zurückkommen.
Oder die Moira könnte ich auch mal heilen.
Moira, hallo.
Ja, da ist mega die Action gerade.
Ich probier's jetzt noch einmal mit Widow.
Ich glaub, die wollen gebasht werden.
Ich werd geschlitzt.
Ich hab null Unterstützung.
Das ist übelst reudig.
Weder der Reinhard, noch der Rotor, noch irgendjemand.
Da sitz ich dafür.
Ja, ich wüsste schon.
Das Team fällt auseinander wie sonst was.
Ja.
Wann hast du das letzte Mal Battlefield 4 gespielt?
Bisschen her. Ja, oder so.
Can you guys come in voice?
Ja, ich komm mal in voice, dass er nicht gleich los tiltet.
Aber daran liegt's nicht wirklich.
Nope.
Ich bin weit, ich bin auf dir.
Ich hab Ult an, ne? Wir können jetzt.
Kriegen wir das Ding durchgepusht?
Müssen wir. Der Genji ist noch Serverraum.
Ups.
Nope.
Moment, mein Retz verschwindet, wenn mich einer wegkickt beim Retzen?
Was ist das denn?
Mercy, sick Mercy Gameplay.
Intens. Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Beste.
Ich bleib mal bei dir.
Damage boost.
Die sind alle oben links.
Und ein paar rechts im, wie auch immer das Ding heißt.
Oh, von hinten, von hinten, von hinten, ein Soldier.
Der hat's auf mich abgesehen.
Oh, oh.
Lieb.
Bleib bei mir.
Nein, ich muss weg, ich muss weg.
Ich bin bei dir.
Ach, diese Heilung, Mann.
Geil.
Huge Mercy Place Chat.
Ich bin übrigens im Voice Chat, es sagt keiner was.
Nicht ein Wort gehört.
Beste.
Klein wieder Ult.
Oh, oh, ich, äh, äh,
ich versuch mal zu dir zu kommen.
Mein Lauf.
Da kommt gleich ein Winston auf dich.
Oh, hab's gesehen.
Äh, schreckt.
Schreckt.
Sushi-Chef am Werk.
Huge, huge, äh,
ja, huge geschlitzt.
Au!
Das Problem ist, so wirklich durchpushen
können wir nicht.
Wenn wir hier uns so einen abstaggern.
Ich mach gleich Ulti an, wenn alle wieder da sind.
Nice.
Uh! Sick!
Sick Helix auf mich in der Luft.
Kann ich nicht heilen,
ich bin tot.
Nice, nice, nice.
Brauchst du Heal? Ich guck grad nicht nach hinten.
Ja, ich bin vor dir.
Über uns, Soldier, über uns, über uns, über uns.
Heal.
Hier hoch.
Okay, ich komm zu dir dann.
Soll da rein.
Bin oben.
Na, warum ist das Kackding jetzt nicht geflogen?
Mach hier,
hinter dir.
Roadhog, Roadhog, komm zurück.
Ey, diese Mercy-Hitboxen, man,
die müssen kotzen.
Ich bin down.
Ich verpiss mich, sofern es geht.
Okay, ich hab jetzt Ulti.
Die haben ihre Ulti raus.
Die haben Mercy-Ulti raus.
Das passt, da können wir jetzt
fett draufputschen noch.
Pushen.
Wenn sie mich verrecken, Leute.
Okay, das ist mehr oder weniger
ihr letzter Push.
Ich muss mich verstecken, bin fast down.
Ich bin auch fast down.
Kannst du mich heilen hinter dir?
Oh, what?
Genji ist oben auf der Brücke.
Ich geh mal hoch.
Genji ist auf mir drauf.
Oh, geschlitzt.
Huge kills, huge kills.
Ich komm mit Lucio wieder, bin schneller da.
Nice.
Wow.
Das ist, ich glaub, die erste Anstrengung.
Ich hab mein Headset-Verstärkungsding
runtergeschmissen, warte mal.
Das passiert,
wenn man hängen bleibt mit dem Stuhl am Kabel.
Ich muss das danach mal fixen,
und dann kann ich das machen.
Ah, jetzt geht's.
Jetzt hör ich mich wieder auf beiden Seiten.
Perfekt.
Ja, ich seh's komisch, muss Mercy spielen.
Es wär geil, wenn wir nen Zenyatta hätten.
Ich würde Zen spielen,
wenn wir ne Mercy hätten.
Ja.
Aber Moiras Zen ist nicht so das...
Weiß, kann man bestimmt gut koordiniert machen.
Lass halt Damage Overkill.
Geht's richtig ab.
Fetzt alles weg.
Nee, ich hätt halt gerne Mercy Zen,
weil man sonst einfach zu wenig Damage hat.
Ja, Mercy Zen ist ja quasi
quasi Meta-Support-Duo aktuell.
Wenn man so guckt.
Max ist doch top Mercy EU.
Ganz, ganz klar.
Ganz klar.
Was meinst du?
Ich find halt, momentan haben die Supporter einfach
viel zu viel Haltung.
Und dann kriegst du die Gegner auch nicht platt.
Wenn du da nicht 10 Headshots am Stück triffst.
Es ist halt so,
so wie ich das sehe,
es ist so ein bisschen komisch verteilt.
Du hast so Helden, die dich instant platzen lassen,
wie Junkrat.
Und du hast Sachen,
als Winston lutschst du 3000
eigentlich unendlich an einem Gegner.
Kriegt sie nicht richtig tot,
wenn er geheilt wird.
Ich bleib mal hier versteckt.
Genji und Mercy in der Mitte.
Lol. Headshot.
Scatter. Scatter.
Scatter.
Och man.
Noch ein Headshot.
Können wir den Winston duschen?
Links ist die Moira tot.
Pass auf, unten Genji.
Der Genji ist übrigens auf mir.
Ich hab Schiss.
Ich muss runter.
Muss ich nicht, muss ich nicht, muss ich nicht.
So nett ey, fuck.
Mercy.
Genji, Genji.
Linke Seite.
Riep.
Genji ist low.
Der Genji ist noch Serverraum.
Der hat gleich Ulti, der hat gleich Ulti.
Ich bin nicht bei dir, ich muss,
ich bin in der Mitte.
Kannst mich hochfliegen lassen?
Kommst du da weg?
Ich geh jetzt zu dir hoch und
Damage booste dich.
Da wird man schon gepusht ja.
Runter.
Fuck ey.
Oh, geschlitzt.
Krass geschlitzt.
Ja, standen alle im Chalkpoint drinne.
Huge Mercy plays.
Aber dafür haben sie viele Ultis los.
War das nicht nur eine?
Wir können das, wir können, ne die Soldier
haben sie, Soldier haben sie, zwei.
Also wir könnten nur contesten mit Moira.
Ja wollen wir nicht, wollen wir nicht.
Jetzt zurück.
Ich fühl mich hier so ein bisschen unwohl.
Huge.
Gehen wir auf den High.
Ja, ich komm gleich zu dir geflogen
wenn das hier zu heiß wird unten.
Max streamt auf Twitch?
Ja, seit einer Weile schon.
Leute.
Ich hab ne Diva am Arsch.
Bin schon dran.
Ich brauch Heilung.
Nevermind.
Damage boost.
Ich flieg zu dir hoch.
Wenn du da bist.
Es gibt halt keinen Grund großartig vor die Türen
zu pushen, wenn man nicht
quasi
da drei, vier Reste aufräumen will.
Bin oben.
Ah, ich seh es.
Ich versteck mich.
Ich bin oben da, auf dem Schiff, wenn du mich
anfliegen kannst.
Da ist ein Rack fest.
Richtig hardcore Grecke.
Rectangle.
Jetzt haben sie einen Reinhard.
Linke Seite.
Ich hab einen Genji auf mir.
Soldier oben.
Kannst du mich anfliegen?
Oh, oh.
Ja.
Soldier wieder oben.
Fuck, down.
Hab so viel geretzt, wie ging.
Zeit ist okay.
Wir können das auf jeden Fall nochmal easy contesten.
Sag mal Marc, spielst du auch nochmal Battlefield 3?
Kommst du mit?
Stimmt.
Ich bin da.
Schnell, schnell, ich muss denen helfen, gleich oben.
Ich werd geschlitzt.
Super, super ey.
Wieso pushen die denn nicht?
Kein Bock. Freu dich.
Die Moira hinter den Gegnern.
Was für ein Failplay.
Mega ein Failplay von der Moira.
Au.
Och man.
Ja, zurück in den Spawn.
Wir räumen uns sonst auf.
Müssen aufpassen, ob der Earthshatter hat.
Hast du geguckt, wann der das letzte Mal
geshattert hat?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab's alles gesehen.
Da flieg ich garantiert nicht rein, um dich zu retzen, Genji.
Ist auch nicht fehl.
Ich flieg zu dir hoch.
Was hast du erwartet?
Bin da oben.
Dauert nicht lang, bis der Genji...
Ich bin wieder unten.
Ich hab wieder Ult hier.
Geh wieder hoch.
Ja, das klappt ganz gut.
Der Genji dasht garantiert jetzt hoch,
dann flieg ich wieder runter.
Da ist er zumindest beschäftigt.
Er will sich ja jetzt seinen Keks abrunden.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich.
Jetzt musst du glaube ich rüber fliegen.
Letzter Fight.
Ich bin da.
Fuck, ich bin halt auch verreckt.
Jetzt kommen die Overtime.
Wir können natürlich nicht mehr spawnen.
Ich komm jetzt los, Jo.
Ich warte auf dich und bring den Reinhardt mit rein.
Du bist raus.
Ich bin dran.
Reinhardt ist fast tot.
Fuck, an der Brücke oben.
Oh.
Overtime.
Yeah.
Dreck.
Weißt du.
Wie sie sich selbst feiern.
Guck mal.
So genau, wie wir den letzten Teamfight verloren haben,
habe ich nicht verstanden.
Wir hatten einen Pick.
Plus, dass ich noch Gold auf 2 gerettet habe.
Gut, ich meine, ich bin in dem Ulti-Gewitter untergegangen.
Aber eigentlich hätten wir den haben müssen.
Den letzten Teamfight.
Ähm.
Wenn wir halt nicht im Ulti-Gewitter gestorben wären.
Bei wie viel SR sind wir momentan?
Wir sind bei 3.709.
Und ich muss immer noch Mercy spielen.
Weil die Mercy-Mains schon alle High-Grammaster sind.
Allerdings, letztes Game hatten wir
einen 46-Stunden-Mercy.
Dafür hat er relativ wenig gemacht, oder?
Für 46 Stunden Mercy.
20 Euro, wenn du bis Ende des Streams GM bist.
Recht unwahrscheinlich.
Aber ich kann ja nicht verlieren.
Entweder kriege ich 20 Euro oder nicht.
Die habe ich ja auch so nicht.
Also.
Bastion Strats.
Übrigens, es sagt im Voice-Chat keiner was.
Auch wenn man im Voice-Chat kommen soll.
Hinterher, Genji.
Genji.
Äh, wir müssen mit.
Also, ich verreck.
Nicht.
Wenn der Bastion sich halt mal umdrehen würde.
Ey, der ist halb AFK, man.
Ich kann mich nicht bewegen hier.
Die Moira.
Rektorino.
Aber dank Overtime,
beziehungsweise kein Overtime,
spawnen sie jetzt natürlich schon relativ schnell.
Das heißt, wir können noch was bashen da.
Oben ist ein Genji. Oben links.
Der könnte Ult gleich haben.
Lol.
Jetzt ist er auf einem Ball gestorben.
Jep.
Was ist das hier für ein Ding, ey?
Oh, oh, oh.
Ich versuche zu dir zu kommen.
Ich habe ein Medpack.
Gehst du wieder runter?
Jaja, ich bin so halbe, halbe, halbe.
Der Rein hat keinen Earthshatter da drauf, klar.
Die können nicht mehr alle so weit von Ult weg sein.
Ach komm, ey.
Fuck.
Der hat durch Ult jetzt auch nichts mehr gebracht.
Aber sind ganz gut.
Komm.
In der Minute.
Huge Bastion Blaze.
Ich bin zwar mit Ult gestorben,
aber das hätte es nicht gerissen.
Ich hätte den Soldier killen können,
aber manchmal.
Moment.
Bastion Defense falle ich wenig von.
Ich finde, man ist da oben, wenn man Highcorn steht,
fast schon zu weit weg, um effektiv Damage
machen zu können.
Außer, wenn die halt gerade die Ecke an dir vorbeifahren.
Immer, wenn ich Mercy spiele...
Ich weiß nicht, ob Dive Combo so sinnvoll ist
wie in der Moira.
Mein Monitor...
Mein Game
plinkt.
Leute, sieht man das auch im Stream?
Na, jetzt geht's.
Ne, Dive Combo
mit Moira ist...
Naja, die muss mitdiven.
Dive Moira.
Das Problem ist halt der fehlende Discord-Opt.
Da fällt halt nix um.
Chat, habt ihr verstanden, was er gerade
gesagt hat?
Was will er?
Ich versteh's nicht.
Jetzt sagt er schon wieder All Voice,
der hat doch noch nie gesprochen.
Doch, er hat gerade irgendwas gesagt,
ich soll nicht nur dich boosten oder so.
Hast du ja nicht.
Mach ich auch nicht.
Ich bin bei dir.
Fuck.
Ich bin wieder oben.
Ok, runter, runter, trocken.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Dive Combo ist für nen Arsch.
Joa, das sagt.
Ok, zurück regroupen.
Regroupen, regroupen, regroupen, Leute, regroupen.
Die pushen.
Also, ich geh jetzt rein, YOLO.
Ja, YOLO-Style.
Die anderen gehen nicht hin, ok.
Haben keinen Bock.
Das war ja der unkoordinierteste
Kack aller Zeiten.
Orisa?
Ach jetzt, weil er jetzt Bastion hat.
Aber wir haben doch schon Reinhardt.
Ja super, die Tracer stirbt halt 10 Jahre spät.
Ist das zum Kotzen.
Ok, ok, wir können jetzt noch richtig gut
einmal ordentlich viben und gut essen.
Was machen die denn da oben?
Ja, Soldier geht nicht down,
wir verrecken, GG.
Das ist einfach Fail gewesen,
Alter.
Ich krieg den nicht down?
Krasser Fail.
Boah.
Selbst mit Ulti, mit Genji Blade, kriegst du den nicht down.
Ohne Discord-Op ist es
verschissen.
Ah, ist echt Fail.
Ok.
Ich zieh raus.
Flawless Dream ist vorbei, Leute.
Das war total unkoordiniert.
Erst oben, dann irgendwie komischer
Fight am Punkt.
Total wir.
I don't know. Aber Dive-Combo ohne Zen,
das ist halt brainfucked.
Platin-Niveau.
Also, keine Ahnung.
So, mal gucken, ob ich
irgendwas im Chat
überlesen hab.
Bei wieviel SR hab ich glaube ich
schon gezeigt.
Jetzt sind wir wieder, wir sind gedroppt.
Game verloren. Gleich mal
fette 28 Punkte runter.
Aber wir können nicht alles gewinnen.
Gestern haben wir komplett alles
gerockt. Flawless 8-0. Easy.
Easy Clap. Rekt.
Tyrannosaurus rekt.
Schreckt. Alles zusammen gestern.
Das war ja, ich glaub so viel in Folge
hab ich noch nie gewonnen.
Was arbeitest du?
Ich kümmere mich
hauptsächlich um unsere Software-Verwaltung.
Repo-Management.
Source-Code.
Ja, Sam Fisher. Moira ist
so langsam aber sicher.
Ich guck mir ja auch immer,
wenn ich Zeit hab, die
Pro-Streams an.
Moira scheint da ziemlich stark im Kommen
zu sein, wenn man sich
anschaut, wie
viele die zurzeit üben.
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass wenn
Moira überhaupt nicht viable
wäre in Pro-Matches,
dass dann so viele Pro-Streams in ihrem Stream
so hard practicen,
wie man das zurzeit sieht.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Hallo Xului.
Magst nichts gegen dich, aber hör auf zu
ziehen.
Ja, wenn du das sagst, dann lass mich
überlegen.
Da hab ich auch gar nicht dran gedacht.
Gut, dass du mir das gesagt hast.
Ähm.
Was ist mit Dr. Kabum passiert?
Nichts. Was soll mit ihm passiert sein?
Also, dem geht's gut.
Dem geht's gut.
Dann mach mal mehr Videos.
Vor allem noch mehr, ne?
Ah, dann bei der Gelegenheit kann ich ja
grad mal auf YouTube reingucken.
So.
Es überfordert mich immer
multitasking-technisch,
zu streamen, zu gucken
hier ingame, Chat, Twitch,
plus ab und zu mal auf YouTube rein.
Das ist einfach zu...
Das schafft mein 33-jähriges Gehirn nicht mehr.
So, wieder da. Kannst queuen.
Ja, Zpro, so ist es, ne?
Er hat uns die Augen geöffnet.
Hat uns die Augen geöffnet.
Also Jax, wir müssen jetzt leider den Stream beenden,
weil einer im Chat hat gesagt, ich soll aufhören.
Ich hab's vorher einfach nicht für möglich gehalten,
aber jetzt, jetzt seh ich's.
What the fuck?
Ich queue.
Wie geht's dem Friseur? Dem geht's auch gut.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen...
Friseur?
Ausrufezeichen Fabian, Ausrufezeichen Frisi.
Eins dieser Kommandos. Ich glaub Ausrufezeichen Fabian ist es.
Er ist auch auf Twitch aktiv.
Und streamt ziemlich viel Black Desert online.
Das ist ein MMO.
Und crimet sich da den ganzen Tag.
Oh, er streamt aktuell sogar.
Seh ich grade.
Er streamt aktuell.
Wollen wir D.Va Winston Action machen?
Nee, nicht mit den Heilern.
Sag ich dir ehrlich.
Nein, wollen wir nicht. Hast du recht.
Ich verschaffe mal ein bisschen Self-Heal.
Ich nehm da Maisel.
Moin Pizzi.
Können die mal aufhören mit ihrer scheiß Moira?
Die stehen da voll drauf.
Ey, es prägt.
Da sind ganz viele Pros zur Zeit Moira,
da ist was im Busch.
Da ist was im Busch.
Moira hat demnächst Hardcore-Meta
und ohne Moira ein Must-Have
geht nix.
Ich seh's zwar auch noch nicht.
Guck mal, die Orisas sind
keine Physikobjekte hier im Startbereich.
Ich bin enttäuscht, Blizzard.
Oh Mann ey.
Das ist so ein schimmeliges Team-Setup.
No Hawk.
No Hawk. Okay.
Was dann?
Komm, ich mach mal, dass er gleich nicht lostiltet.
Nicht, weil ich es für sonderlich sinnvoll halte,
da etwas anderes zu spielen.
Aber ich will nicht, dass er gleich lostiltet.
Du kennst die Leute.
Guck, ich bin übrigens low die ganze Zeit.
Ich bin übrigens low die ganze Zeit.
Ich geh rein, ich geh rein, ich geh rein.
Und Sen hinter uns, hinter uns, Sen.
Geflankt ist Tony.
Das ist der letzte Ulti, das...
Warum hatte die bitteschön schon...
Alter.
Warum hat die das überlebt so lange?
Da, da weißt du schon warum.
Oh, jetzt haben wir eine Ana, jetzt wird alles besser.
Das war eine schnelle Fahrer-Ulti.
Das war außergewöhnlich schnell.
So schnell geht das eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich will hier auch nicht durch, aber was...
Ich hab so echt...
Ich bin übrigens fast down.
Hahaha, das wird wieder was.
Ja, jetzt könnte man wenigstens halt mal die Moira fressen, ne?
Wenn man eine Mercy hätte.
Boah, das ist so fail.
Was sind die denn alle?
Na, wollen alle durch den Tunnel oben durch.
Boah.
I don't know.
Das ist zum Verlieren verurteilt.
Das ist wieder Wahnsinn, ey.
Aber wir können nicht jeden Tag alles gewinnen.
Ja, aber das sind die Matches,
Ja, aber das sind die Matches, die wieder traurig sind.
Warum wollen die unbedingt da oben durch?
Komm, wir flanken jetzt außen links lang.
In der Mitte ist ein Winston.
Die sind jetzt scheinbar schon oben.
Hinter uns ein Winston.
Das ist mega...
Oh, huge!
Ich krieg aber halt keinen Heal.
Die nächste Pharaon.
Ne, du mit Reinhard klappt das nicht.
Ich krieg noch nicht mal Charge.
Ich krieg noch nicht mal Ultimate.
Ich nehm jetzt irgendwas anderes.
Winston, komm.
Sollen wir uns nochmal einen Smurf machen?
Damit wir wieder fähige Teammates haben?
Das ist halt einfach Pech.
Komm, wir haben so gerockt die letzten Tage.
Da oben ist ja gar nix.
Leute, wo sollt ihr denn?
Da ist die Mercy down.
Helpp!
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was hier abgeht.
Was ist Max sein Career High?
Ich glaube auf Main war es das höchste Mal irgendwie 3900.
Hinter euch ne Phara.
Komm, die wird jetzt gebasht.
Nein!
Oh Mann, ey.
Fail.
Jetzt bist du ja auch auf dem Spot.
Das ist ja wieder ne absolut verkackte Scheiße.
Oh, huge res.
So, Sen ist tot.
Oh, schwere Geburt.
Echt schwere Geburt.
Wahnsinn.
Komm, ne Moira-Kugel angeflogen.
Ja, ist ja gut.
Ich glaub, du bist ein bisschen YOLO.
Ich war ein bisschen sehr YOLO und hab das Schild an die falsche Stelle gesetzt.
Aber die sollen ruhig Ulz raushauen.
Haut Ulz raus, Leute.
Haut alles raus.
Komm einfach durch.
Ich hab Ulz hier.
Ja, jetzt kommt der Spawn-Rate des Todes.
Der Winston ist über uns.
Geh auch mal hoch.
Winston schläft hinten.
Ich kick die anderen weg.
Mach den tot.
Warum krieg ich nen Nano-Boost?
Fahrer über euch.
Sen ist weg.
Gegen Schild gehöppt.
Push, push, push.
Die Gegner sind nicht mal gut.
Die haben schlechte Movements.
Da kannst du ein bisschen Winston üben.
Winston ist weg.
Help, Leute, help!
Ich mach sie am Arsch der Welt.
Ist Winston das Äffchen?
Nein, das ist der Wissenschaftler.
Das ist Clientist.
Okay, ich rack.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, Mick!
Gehst du rein?
Ich komm mit.
Ich bin dran.
Die kriegen wir.
Wo ist die Fahrer?
Pass down.
Geht ein Spawn rein.
Ich hab sie.
Nice.
Das war auf dem letzten Drücker, ne?
Mhm.
Huge Winston plays.
Winston macht übelst Bock.
Den muss ich auf jeden Fall mal üben.
Ich merk das noch.
Ich kann es überhaupt nicht richtig einschätzen,
so mit Winkel, wie du springen musst.
Jetzt macht er dir noch Spaß.
Warte mal, bis du richtig gute Gegner triffst.
Dann fuckt er dich nur noch ab.
Dann kann man eine Sekunde aus dem Bildschirm treten.
Ja, komm.
Aber wenn die mit Fahrer ankommen,
brauchen wir...
Mach wieder Winston.
Huge Win, nice, nice.
Noch ist ja kein Win.
Ich frag mich halt echt,
ob sich das YouTube nicht anders vorgestellt hat,
dass man diese Community-Funktion als Stream-Werbung
für Twitch verwendet.
So geil, das einzige, was ich gepostet hab,
ist Stream live.
Stream live.
Bin wieder live auf Twitch.
Das haben die sich garantiert nicht so vorgestellt.
Wenn der Hawk jetzt noch auf D.Va wäre,
das wäre ganz nice.
Ich bin eh wieder mit Fahrer und so.
Das wird interessant.
Und Leute, wartet schon im neuen Star-Wars-Film.
Ich bin jetzt mal ganz ketzerisch und sage,
ich werde ihn mir nicht angucken,
weil ich kein Star-Wars-Fan bin.
Stream auf YouTube.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Hast du Tipps, um aus Gold rauszukommen?
Ja.
Viel spielen erstmal.
Das ist eigentlich der wichtigste Tipp.
Viel spielen und sich selbst eingestehen,
und dann ist es einfach so,
dass du dich nicht mehr mit dem Team befestigen kannst.
Das ist einfach so.
Und dann kommt ein bisschen was.
Au.
Die pushen rechts durch.
Können wir da reinspringen?
Ja, ja, ja, go.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, fuck, ich muss weg.
Oh, Rekt, Rekt, Rekt, Rekt.
Ich hab meine Deflektor-Zone,
wo ich hinter den Gegnern stomme.
Oh, ich bin gegen ein Schild gesprungen,
wie der letzte Kack-Noob.
Ich brauch Hilfe.
Oben ist der Soldier über uns.
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
Das waren jetzt zu viele.
Zu langsam gestorben.
Gleich Ulti.
Zumindest fällt es mir zum ersten Mal auf,
dass es eigentlich wichtig ist,
zu wissen, wo so kleine Hindernisse
auf der Map sind.
Ich bleib's immer dran hängen.
Ich glaub, die Pharah ist oben links drinnen.
Ich bin noch nicht da.
Können wir pushen?
Hinter uns wird noch geretzt.
Da ist noch eine Pharah.
Mercy, Mercy, Mercy.
Schild.
Rein!
Oder auch nicht.
Ich bin drinne.
Ich auch, ich bin auch drin.
Jetzt haben sie uns aber geschnetzelt.
Haben gute Zeit rausgeholt.
Dings Pharah wird auf dem Highground sein.
Ich geh hoch.
Kommst du mit?
Oder wir können nochmal die Payload contesten.
Dann raus.
Ach komm, ein HP.
Ich wollt grad Mele drücken.
Wo sind unsere Huge Rests?
Wir müssen an der Payload bleiben.
Mercy links.
Oh Leute.
Der feedet uns nochmal fette Ultis rein.
So muss das sein.
Ein paar Tipps, wie man sich mit HTML und CSS leichter tut.
Äh, fällt mir jetzt nix ein.
Ich find's an sich...
Einfach dran gewöhnen.
Ja, da ist aber noch nix da.
In der Mitte.
Der Roadhog, der Roadhog ey.
Ich hab ihm ein Schild gesetzt.
Ohhhh.
Er ist verloren.
Gerade noch Schild setzen.
Alles angefangen mit dem Roadhog,
wo Super-Ulzi reingeht, ey.
Wo willst n' Ult, fühl ich mich komplett unfähig noch mit.
Weil mit ein bisschen hin und her schubsen ist es ja nicht getan.
Können wir? Ich hab Blade.
Ja, ich hab Schild.
3, 2, 1.
Der Roadhog, was geht mit dem ab?
Ich spiel jetzt mal ne D.Va.
Mercy, wo bist du denn?
Mercy!
BTF!
Mercy, BTF, was war das denn?
Meine Güte, ey.
Trotz Nanoblade,
zack, down, instant.
Ohhhh, was war das
für nen scheiß Blade.
Also man, die Winston-Blades waren auch nicht gut, aber was hat...
Was denkt man sich denn
dabei?
So, jetzt kein Winston.
Ich spiel jetzt Roadhog.
Ich hab das Gefühl, ich verreck sonst
eh, kann ich mich wenigstens selbst halten.
Ja, jetzt haben wir wieder
dasselbe Problem-Setup wie davor.
Ja, bloß diesmal Roadhog statt Reinhard.
Und du wieder.
Das kann schon gut funktionieren.
Stimmt, ne Orisa wär
nicht verkehrt.
Mit dem Turret.
Ich würde...
Ich würde Orisa gehen, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es
schaffe rechtzeitig.
Lucio pickt mich ab.
Pange ich nicht rechtzeitig.
Der Lucio ist auch wieder komplett brain-up, Leute.
Kannst du mir das sagen, dass ich gleich dahin laufe?
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Steht noch gar keiner scheinbar.
Ich schieß mal was zu dir hoch.
Ich seh in Mitte.
Die Dive für dich
hardcore.
Soldier, down.
Mercy, Mercy down. Mercy ist weg.
Help, Leute.
Please. Schon vorbei.
Zwei Leute gekillt, inklusive von Mercy.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Oh Gott.
Was ein Game.
Haben die Gegner gut gemacht.
So sieht eine Live-Kombo aus.
Oh.
Nix mit flawless winning stream.
Oh Mann, ey.
Auer Stream.
Kannst queuen.
Ich kann queuen?
Jedes Season wird schlimmer.
Ja, bei Blizzard.
Man kann ja nur
beschränkt den Leuten
einen Vorwurf machen, finde ich.
Zwar auch, ja.
Aber Blizzard muss das auch ordentlich umsetzen.
Seit Season 2 oder so
hat sich ja an der Sache nichts geändert.
Ich mein, wenn ja,
es ist ja nicht so, dass von Anfang an
über das Ranking-System geflamed wurde.
Und jetzt kommen sie auf die Idee,
performance-based Matchmaking
ist keine so gute Idee.
So.
Hab ich irgendwas überlesen im Chat?
Nee, sieht nicht so aus.
Achso, ja, noch was zum Thema.
Bist du noch da?
.polarized
Ja, du bist noch da.
Also, zu HTML und CSS.
Das einzige, was mir einfällt,
was man machen kann,
dass es ein bisschen leichter fällt,
ist quasi nicht in der Datei rumeditieren,
reloaden und gucken,
sondern die Zeiten zwischen
editieren und anzeigen möglichst kurz zu machen.
Entweder, indem du im Browser selbst,
in den Browser-Entwicklungstools selbst
ein bisschen rumprobierst,
also direkt siehst, wie sich was auswirkt,
was du machst auf der Seite.
Oder du kannst einen Editor verwenden,
mit so,
der sich quasi so mit dem Browser connectet
und quasi du schreibst was live im Editor
und es ändert sich auf der Seite.
Oder wenn das nicht geht,
nimmst du irgend so einen Live-Reload-Plugin,
dass du quasi bei jedem Mal speichern
das automatisch den Browser reloadest.
Da musst du nicht jedes Mal den Browser anklicken,
Fünf drücken und so, das ist nervig.
Werden Helden beim Balancing immer geschwächt?
Die würden irgendwann kein Damage mehr machen?
Nee. Wenn du dir Junkrat anguckst,
Junkrat wurde nicht geschwächt.
Junkrat wurde OP-gebufft.
Das hat angefangen mit zwei Minen,
glaube ich, oder?
Mhm. Genau, zwei Minen.
Dann irgendwann, dass er immun war gegen
Damage. Ich glaube, das war nicht der gleiche Patch.
Beide habe ich nicht gespielt.
In der Zeit habe ich nur so auf Reddit verfolgt.
Ja.
Kannst du dich noch an das
Taschentuch-Tire erinnern
aus der Beta?
Angehustet und weg.
Taschentuch-Tire?
Na, das Tire vom Junkrat,
das hatte 25 oder 50 TP
mal kurzzeitig.
Das hast du angespuckt, das war kaputt.
Das war noch nice.
Ja, Beta habe ich nicht gezuckt.
Moment.
Jetzt geht es halt schon wieder los mit diesen...
Weißt du, das hasse ich.
Moment.
So ab Blademaster kannst du die ganzen
Spieler einfach in die Tonne klopfen.
Während ich so jetzt tanken, oder was?
Ich weiß nicht.
Okay, komm, wir machen jetzt Tank-Action.
Wollen wir Dive-Tank-Action machen,
oder wollen wir...
Ne, wir machen mal wieder die Reinhardt
und D.Va-Kombi oder sowas.
Wobei, du hast halt nicht gescheit...
Wir haben nicht gescheit Heal, oder du zumindest nicht,
wenn du reingehst.
Naja, eigentlich habe ich ja überhaupt kein Heal
mit den zwei Supportern.
Kannst du knicken,
ich probiere es mal wieder.
Hallo Lars, X-Cape?
X-Cape?
Aber mit Speed ist schon immer angenehm.
Ich muss pushen.
Alles low, aber nix stirbt.
Genji auf mir.
D.Va ist auch noch.
Genji ist hinter uns, ich push weiter.
Genji kommt hoch zu dir.
Ist rechts hinter dir im Gang.
D.Va fast tot.
Der...
Demnächst Ulti.
Erstes Team, den du siehst.
Ja, aktuell bin ich ziemlich viel am streben.
Wo sind auf einmal alle hin?
Alle verreckt. Gut.
Das war vielleicht ein bisschen sehr YOLO-Style gerade.
Die Genji ist durch mich durchgedasht,
war hinter mir, ich habe ihr einen Headshot gegeben.
Auf eine unsichtbare Hitbox geschossen.
He.
Rumble.
Oh, oh,
ich shatter die jetzt gleich so krass.
Juuuut, shatter.
Hehehehehe.
Voll.
Dieser Moment, wo du nach oben Grappling Hook machst
und eine D.Va-Ulti ins Gesicht fliegt.
Perfekt.
Scheiß drauf, ich mache jetzt
eine D.Va-Ulti rein, Hart.
Nein.
Help. Nice.
Wir haben ganz gute Picks.
Ich muss wieder vorlaufen.
Max, wann kommt eigentlich Sub-Button?
Habe ich mich noch nicht drum gekümmert.
Let's break it da.
Easy.
Kommt gleich nochmal was.
Da wird gehämmert.
Max, Vollzeitstreamer.
Ja, ich habe Urlaub, da geht das auch.
Auto, fahre.
Weiß Picks.
Ach lol.
Ich dachte, das ist zu euch rüber geflogen.
Es war auch bei uns drüben.
Aber auch Highcrown ist alle
zerberstet.
Jaja, lasst die alle schönen Ultis verschwenden.
Lasst die alle schönen Ultis verschwenden.
Doppelkill. Heilung.
Juuuut.
Kack Mercy.
Ich pushe. Juuuut, shatter Leute.
Rechts Mercy.
Mercy rechts.
Mercy links.
Weiß. Da wurde durchgehämmert.
Äh, Last Escape finde ich total bescheuert.
Braucht man nicht.
Uiuiui.
So.
Äh, Defense, da bleibt mir nicht viel anderes übrig.
Sam Fisher, den gucke ich auch gern.
Vor allem mit seinem komischen Text-to-Speech.
Das finde ich lustig. Erstmal eine Abwechslung.
Außer bei Stream-Grills.
Da kann es auch Bootcamp statt Facecam geben.
Und die Leute finden es geil.
Willst du mit der Ecke contesten?
Oder willst du...
Ah ne, du bist Widow.
Ne, wahrscheinlich willst du überhaupt nicht
obendrauf contesten.
Äh, eher weniger.
Ui.
Ich bleibe oben.
Sag denen doch, dass
unser Setup ist.
What the fuck.
Moin, Lefi.
Die Mercy hat mich lieb geworden.
Sie boostet mich.
Jetzt geht es ab.
Mach sie fertig.
Haha, Evoli.
Ja, habe ich.
Lass es nochmal von jemand anderem angucken.
Ich bleibe mal hier drauf stehen.
Wenn du Hilfe brauchst in der Nähe, sag Bescheid.
Nice.
Hat wieder geretzt.
Das Schild geht gleich kaputt.
Ich gehe jetzt runter, contesten.
Das Schild geht kaputt.
Bum.
Bum. Big Shuck.
Skrrr.
Oh, oh, die haben auch nur Widow jetzt am Start.
Widow ist oben, in der Mitte.
Hopp, hüpft drauf.
Genjis sind uns.
Nicht mehr.
Wohin ist denn oben?
Wir sollten nicht so sehr contesten
in der Mitte.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ich da von diesem LK ähm
Zug oder was das sein soll.
Wo ist die Tracer?
Tracer in euch drin?
Fuck.
Widow ist in der Mitte.
Ich lasse das Schild oben.
Moment mal, verrecken irgendwie gerade alle?
Ja.
Die winsten auf mir, ey.
Wir können das noch halten.
Widow ist hinter euch, ne?
Ich habe die Mercy, klar.
Huge.
Oh.
Nicht huge.
Viele erwischt, aber kein Follow-Up.
War schon alles tot.
Ja, die Widow macht gerade die Spawn-Rate.
Das Widow ist halt
AFK hinter mir hergelaufen.
Ah, das ist jetzt auch absoluter Fail von mir,
dass ich nicht geguckt habe, wie viele Leute noch leben.
Ich finde es aber auch schwierig, als Tank
einen Überblick zu behalten.
Gehen wir ran. Widow in der Mitte.
Ich bin am Contesten.
Widow in der Mitte.
Versucht zu hammern, sonst ist...
Ich habe da was.
Winston ist weg.
Widow, Widow, Mitte, Mitte, Mitte.
Ich bleibe in der Mitte stehen mit dem Schild.
Pass auf nicht hinein.
Oh Mann, ey.
Ich bekomme keinen Freiraum mehr,
sonst ist es zum Katzen.
Die Mercy ist in der Tankstelle unten.
Die sind aber so geil auf mich, ey.
Die haben mich hier gefühlt
dreimal über die ganze Map gekickt.
Gute Zeit, gute Zeit.
Alles gut.
Abends.
Zurückkommen.
Zurück.
Mach dein Schild hoch.
Er ist schon am Start.
Linke Seite oben.
Jetzt wieder runter.
Tracer hinter uns.
Fang an zu hammern.
Ein Hit.
Geht rechts durch.
Wenn der Winston das Schild raus hat,
ist er weg.
Wie viele leben noch genug?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube nicht.
Irgendwas war noch hinter uns.
Ach, die Diva.
Ich glaube, ich habe oben im Gang was gehört.
Mit Zen.
Oben links im Gang.
Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe.
Die Diva ist nicht im Auto drin.
Die können wir erstmal so lassen.
Äh, ja.
Die sind oben drauf.
Richtig.
Ich würde gerade sagen, ne?
Tracer hüpft auch noch unten rum.
Fast tot.
Sniper.
Noch Mercy.
Wallhack.
Ich brauche Hilfe.
WTF.
Overtime-Kacke.
Aber Zeit ist gut.
Der Top-Guard 420.
Das Ganze knicken.
Fast Zeit ist top.
Easy win jetzt.
Was?
Wieso bin ich jetzt in Metra?
WTF?
Nee, bist du nicht.
Ach, du hast gesp...
WTF?
Was war das denn?
Tracer, come on.
Das Schlimme ist halt,
gegnerische Widow hat Freiraum des Todes.
Ich habe gar keinen.
Genji wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt.
Komm mal ein bisschen zurück.
Die sind alle drin bei uns oben jetzt.
Jutsch.
Aufwärts senden die immer so des Todes.
Ich will jetzt hier nicht fighten in Unterzahl.
Kannst du ein bisschen zurückkommen?
Ja.
Aber unser Zarya geht dran.
Wird gefressen, ne?
Ja.
Ich bin gestucked.
Hilfe.
Also einmal noch regroupen und dann...
Einmal regroupen.
Ich habe halt schön rausgeschattert.
Ist gestorben.
Das Linkshaus, Linkshaus.
Warte noch.
Jetzt raus.
Die gehen natürlich rechts raus,
für die Bots.
C9.
Huge C9.
Diamond last season please.
Nein, mich kann er nicht meinen.
Ich war auf gar nichts auf dem Account.
Nice.
Also der Anfang von dem Game war richtig geil,
danach...
Aber die haben es auch gut gemacht,
also der Widowpick hat uns wirklich
ziemlich Probleme bereitet.
Vielleicht wäre es auch besser gewesen,
wir hätten...
Wobei, wir hatten einen Winston, oder?
Hatten wir einen Winston?
Ne, wir hatten keinen Winston.
Wenn wir einen hatten, haben wir ihn zumindest kaum gesehen.
Also wenn irgendwie einer noch Genji Winston gepickt hätte,
einfach um die Widow mehr zu ficken.
Ich bin mal kurz 3 Minuten AFK.
Ja, guck ich mal.
Guck mal in die Follows rein,
was es da so Neues gibt.
Oh, danke für die Follows.
Ich kann leider noch die letzten vorlesen,
weil mehr sehe ich nicht.
Danach sehe ich dann wieder nur vor 3 Tagen.
Ähm...
TheLeggingMoritz,
Maschkunz,
DSRTVPR712.
Also, muss ich sagen,
linguistisch der beste Name
des heutigen Abends.
HeisenbergHeid,
Senuit18,
MeisterMaggan05,
DerRaupenHugo,
und DotPolarized.
Mehr sehe ich leider nicht.
Doch, Kommandostich und Schaffus.
Mehr sehe ich nicht.
Willkommen im Strem.
Äh, DasEfolie, wusstest du eigentlich
vor dem FaceReveal von Anotrex, wie er aussieht?
Ich glaube schon.
Wann hat er denn FaceRevealed?
Als erstes Mal
habe ich ihn auf der Gamescom getroffen.
Und ich glaube,
da hat er noch nicht FaceRevealed.
Glaube ich.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber da wusste ja auch von mir keiner, wie ich aussehe.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Kann sein.
Ja, dann war das vor 4 Jahren auf der Gamescom.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt, wie da die zeitlichen Abläufe
waren, so genau.
20cm deutscher Stahl.
Hast du ein LPG-Cert?
Und verwendet ihr Docker?
Ich habe kein LPG-Cert.
Ich versuche mit Ewigkeiten,
meinen LPG zu machen.
Also erstens sehe ich nicht so,
was es mir jetzt direkt bringen würde,
wenn ich das mache.
Und auf der anderen Seite bin ich sehr faul,
was sowas anbelangt.
Das wird mir was bringen, wenn ich mir mal
einen neuen Job suchen muss, will,
was auch immer.
Aber so jetzt?
Weiß nicht.
Ich spiele schon jahrelang mit dem Gedanken,
ob ich es nicht mal machen soll.
Wir verwenden Docker.
Beziehungsweise wir verwenden Container.
Allerdings
gibt es ja noch mehr Frontends.
Also noch andere Frontends
als Docker.
Habe ich eigentlich aktualisiert hier?
Ja, aber es waren ein paar huge Shatters dabei heute.
Ich hoffe,
die werden auch mal geklippt und nicht nur
immer meine Fails. Habe ich eigentlich schon erzählt,
dass ich in irgendeinem Overwatch-Win-und-Fail-Video
gelandet bin?
Hat mir heute einer auf Twitter gepostet.
Guck mal, ob ich es finde.
Was ist denn?
Hm.
Hat mir heute jemand gepostet auf Twitter?
Das kann doch nicht so lange her sein.
Ah, hier!
Overwatch Daily Moments Episode 258
Funny and Random Moments
Bei sieben Minuten.
Wir können uns das ja mal zusammen angucken.
Es ist total unspektakulär.
Display Capture.
Moment, ich habe ja schon Display Capture.
Da und da bin ich dabei
mit irgendeinem Clip bei
57.
Also da irgendwo.
Ja, das ist mal...
Boah, die Quali ist aber mal unter aller Sau.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie den Clip gefunden haben.
Das ist, wo ich mit dem Reinhard
hammere und danach wird das Game abgebrochen.
Next Level.
Next Level Hammer.
Kick the Reno, get up.
Rekt. 5k. Rekt.
Fand ich ganz lustig.
Wie funktioniert das mit dem Nightbot?
Was meinst du?
Du musst ein Kommando schreiben und dann antwortet dir ein Nightbot was.
Also kannst du
zum Beispiel Ausrufezeichen Grill machen.
Dann kriegst du ein Amazon
Refling zu Grills.
Ich meine, wer jetzt was anderes vermutet hat, sollte mal
seine Twitch-D-Gewohnheiten überprüfen.
Bereust du eigentlich
früher welche gepusht zu haben, ohne Namen zu nennen?
Hm.
Ja.
Ein.
Wbe.
Ganz cute.
Jo. Go, go.
3-2.
Also das Flawless Winning Stream
hat sich erledigt heute.
Aber nachdem wir so viel
die letzten Tage gewonnen haben,
es ärgert mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht so.
Und ich würde vorschlagen, mal angenommen,
wir hätten mal den übelsten Losing Streak,
da machen wir einfach noch 3-4 Losses in Folge.
Machen wir einfach Schluss.
Sonst ist der Tilt einfach wieder so übertrieben,
dass wir dann in den nächsten paar Tagen keinen Bock mehr haben zu spielen.
Das muss ja nicht sein.
Ich glaube, eines der größten Fehler,
die man machen kann, ist,
quasi trotz Megatilt immer wieder direkt
nach dem Game zu sagen, weiter queuen.
Weiter queuen, weißt du?
Siehst du ja auch in Streams total oft.
Die tilten sich dann da 3-4 Stunden von Match zu Match.
Ja gut, was soll man machen?
Ja.
Ja, aber danach wird es ja trotzdem nicht besser.
Ist ja nicht das Problem.
Nee, aber du hast dich
Nee, das nicht,
aber du hast dich wahrscheinlich schon wieder ein bisschen abgeregt,
dass es dich da nicht mal ganz so sehr nervt.
Mercy Main, by the way,
ist bei uns.
Na, der wird aber mal hoffentlich Mercy spielen,
der kann nicht als Lucio spielen.
Mercy Main, by the way,
hat übrigens 64 Stunden Tracer und 33 Genji.
Und Mercy gar nicht.
Hat Sia.
Sia, das ist bestimmt Krill.
27 Stunden Mercy, sonst nichts.
Jawoll!
Da muss ich jetzt mal bei der Gelegenheit
gerade mal gucken.
3700, einfach mal so,
das ist jetzt fies, ja, so exposed,
letzte Season, gibt es nicht zu gucken.
Okay, letzte Season
3100 Diamond.
Mercy,
das liegt nicht an Mercy, das ist einfach
die kontinuierliche Weiterentwicklung
und Verbesserung ingame gewesen.
Von 3000 auf 3700.
Oh!
Kommt jetzt, kommt jetzt hier,
äh, Flank Attack.
Kommst du?
Äh, jo.
Das wissen die Leute da unten nicht.
Ich habe gerade ein bisschen
überhaupt nicht gecheckt,
auf welcher Seite wir sind.
Quick Math.
Schön den Schild ballern,
so wie es das gehört.
Leute, ich habe die Gegner rausgezogen.
Wir werden krass gelasert.
Oh, Huge Res.
Huge Res, Massive
Gigantic Res.
Oh, haha,
overextended des Todes.
Ich cappe mal mit der Mercy,
sofern es geht.
Nein, geht nicht.
Das war Massive
overextended.
Okay, Respawn.
Das war wirklich
overextended von den anderen beiden.
Der Doomfist wird gefistet.
Oben rechts ist ein Zarya.
Gehen wir,
komm, komm, Leute.
Mitte, Mitte.
Nein, Doomfist nicht.
Doomfist hatte ich gedacht.
Mitte ist outdated, overrated,
debated.
Was?
Die sind alle verreckt.
Super.
Okay, ich habe Bronze Damage.
Das geht nicht so gut, würde ich sagen.
Oh, jetzt kommt er mit dem Hanzo.
Ja, auf. Move dich, Alter. Komm her.
Okay.
Speed.
Was ist denn das hier?
Das läuft
ja richtig gut.
Last Hero fragt, was ist denn debated?
Äh,
an emote.
Wir müssen Onspot geben.
Speed.
Die Leute glatzen natürlich nicht.
Das läuft gut, die Runde.
Yeah.
Oh, Leute.
Wir haben einen Punkt.
Mein Gott.
Ich charge mal ein bisschen Old.
Ich gehe mit dem Winston drauf.
Da muss jetzt mal was umkippen.
Oh, das ist jetzt...
Jetzt kommt der Overextend.
Ja.
WTF, Leute, wo seid ihr denn hin?
Das ist ja
massiv unkoordiniertes Zeug
wieder hier.
Ja, das ist die absolute
Uneinigkeit.
Ja, genau. Sollen wir pushen? Sollen wir zurückgehen?
Dann pusht man und denkt, auf geht's.
Und dann gehen wieder alle zurück.
So.
Könnte ich anders machen.
So wirklich großartig Probleme
hervorgestochen. Bei den Gegnern ist jetzt eigentlich keiner,
wo man was gegen machen müsste.
Last Escape sagt, ich finde den
Heal von Lucio zu weak.
Nee, der Heal von Lucio ist richtig so.
Vor allem, wenn Ana mal wieder irgendwann
Meta werden sollte,
dann Metallgranate.
Das wäre schon extrem nice.
Wenn Lucio jetzt noch mehr heilen würde,
dann wäre er wieder
must pick.
Wir wollen wahrscheinlich links contesten,
weil wir einen Orisa haben, aber
nix zum Spammen.
Was ist das wieder für Musik?
Tracer hinter uns.
What the fuck?
Was ist das schon wieder, ey?
Kein Schimmer.
Gibt's den Ausrufezeichen SR?
3700.
So in dem Dreh.
Was ist das für ein Failgame gerade?
Egal.
Auf Leute, go!
Ruft euch!
Ich bin jetzt als erster drinnen
und keiner mehr mit mir.
Oh meine Fresse, ey.
Da geht gar nix.
Das ist auch
null, da fällt überhaupt nix um.
Ich hab keine Ulti.
Moment, wir gehen die Seite raus.
Auch gut.
Dann jetzt auf Leute. Recken.
Tja.
Also das ist gleich schon mal
für nacht.
Das ist halt Latemaster. Ab hier geht's
nur so weiter.
Kann aber eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Ist halt wirklich so, weil die Leute
sind
schwanker zwischen pushen und nicht pushen.
The fuck? Was war das?
Ich nehm ein.
Oh, Hanzo willst du jetzt solo die Tracers
soloen oder was?
Oh Mann.
Ich muss vor zu euch. Der Hanzo stirbt wahrscheinlich gleich gegen die Tracers.
Hier läuft.
Ja.
Hanzo ist gegen Tracers gestorben.
Prediction, Leute. Mega Prediction, oder?
Zurück.
Reckt. Pass auf, da kommen welche durch.
Reckt.
Brauch er wieder Heal?
Es liebt ab des Todes, ey.
Pushen die Leute mal. Pushen die.
Ich hab des...
Oh Mann. Da kommt keiner mit.
Kannste vergessen.
Yorissa steht einfach nur da.
Shit.
Nice. Weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter.
Nice.
Was? Hinter dir, hinter dir.
Kann ich mir nicht machen.
Das war Fail.
Get ticked on.
Das hat
nicht so funktioniert.
Zieh mal raus.
Oh ne, bist du das?
Ne, die andere.
Das war halt
von Anfang an fast schon zum
verlieren verurteilt.
Wollen wir noch eins spielen?
Ja, eins brauchen wir noch. Eins brauchen wir noch.
Komm, 4-3 jetzt. Easy win.
Ich kann ja mit so Team-Setups
wie Yorissa fast gar nichts anfangen.
Das war ja auch noch kacke gespielt.
Du kannst mit Yorissa hier wunderbar Leute mit dieser
Teamcraft auch runterziehen und sowas.
Aber unsere Yorissa hat ja nur
links oben gestanden und hat sich 0
bewegt. Obwohl rechts dann gepusht wurde
und sowas. Und an Stellen, wo du nicht mal richtig
reinschießen kannst.
CP outdated and now we
conquested. Was?
Ja, weil das mit dieser Orisa-
Kugel hängt halt auch immer nur davon ab, ob
der Gegner wirklich so blöd ist,
da im Abgrund zu stehen.
Ja. Zumal die auch immer die andere
Seite gepusht sind. Da ist kein Abgrund.
Also. Ne?
Das hätte doch eh nicht funktioniert.
Aber das sind so Games, die
machen mir am wenigsten Spaß.
Die tilten mich auch richtig krass. Du weißt nicht,
was dein Team macht. Der eine, der
macht dann seine Solo-Flank-Action
und dann geht der Nächste rein und
disengaget sofort wieder und du bist
halt gebaited und am Arsch. Ich finde,
das ist auch eines der größten
Probleme, die das Flank-System hat. Nicht,
dass es im Endeffekt nicht stimmen würde.
Das
wird sich wahrscheinlich durch diese SR-Geschichte
jetzt durch dieses Performance-Zeug erledigen.
Aber so wie es jetzt ist, dass du halt total
viele Games hast, wo du die Gegner fistest
und im nächsten Game dich die Gegner fistest
und du halt wenig wirklich
gute, voller Qualität her, gute Matches
hast.
Das ist das, was ich als eines der
größten Probleme hier vor Matchmaking sehe.
Ähm.
Sam Fisher fragt, ob ich
Dino Flask kenne. Nein, das
sagt mir gar nichts. Was ist das?
Ne, jetzt habe ich noch nicht geguckt.
Schick.
Sam Fisher, schick mir mal das
lustigste Video, was
du da findest von dem. Das können wir uns dann gleich
nochmal angucken zusammen.
Oh, eine Dossi-P-Map. Das hat uns
jetzt gefehlt.
Ich habe
hier am Start
Widow,
Genji, Tracer-Main, Dings-Main.
Okay, wir haben kein Mercy-Main
am Start.
Also, ich mache uns jetzt wieder mit
grandiosem Mercy-Gameplay
beglücken.
Da habt ihr schon alle drauf gewartet, Chat, oder?
Falls der Patrick noch da ist,
der findet das bestimmt geil,
mit den Mercy-Plays.
Geiles Setup. Richtig cool.
Was haben wir denn?
Widow, Junkrat, Hanzo.
So.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist das letzte Abfallsetup.
Es kann keiner, keiner kann
ein Medpack nehmen. Keiner einen.
Geht nicht.
Weißt du, ich habe
angefangen zu lesen,
Mercy, Widow,
Reinhard, Junkrat, habe ich mir gedacht, oh cool, ey,
nice. Und dann habe ich gesehen, Hanzo
ist am Brack. Nein.
Kommst du zu mir?
Hanzo lässt dich einfach
sterben, damit er es lernt.
Ich verstecke mich einfach hier.
Ich schmeiß den jetzt runter.
Ich freue mich schon auf
das Netzneutralitätsvideo auf deinem YouTube-Channel.
Ja, das dauert aber noch ein bisschen.
Ich kann nicht die ganze Zeit
bei dir stehen.
Wir haben keinen Healer sonst.
Ja, die haben ein Sombra.
Haben sie sich verentschieden. Ist ja ein Problem.
Hä, jetzt können wir das machen.
Haben die überhaupt eine Widow oder Gegner?
Ich muss da jetzt heilen.
Und jetzt ist Sombra useless.
Lolli.
Jutsch, Wes. Sag, wenn du
irgendwas brauchst, da oben. Oh Gott, was?
Warum kämpfen wir überhaupt hier drinnen?
Mit Unterzahl.
Ja, da kann ich jetzt nichts machen.
Von hinten spammt ein Junkrat mich an.
Jutsch, Shatter vom Reinhardt. Massive Shatter.
Lolli.
Also, wenn das nur
durchgeht, dann ist das...
Das ist aber wahrscheinlich auch, weil die Gegner
noch mehr abkacken. Kannst du auf mir hier bleiben?
Mit Damage.
Kann aber sein, dass ich gleich runter muss.
Junkrat kriegt recht schon richtig
auf den Sack.
Ja, ich muss ab und zu aber andere heilen.
Jetzt kann ich wieder zu dir.
Ich hab gleich Ulti.
Ne, ich geh nochmal wieder runter.
Viel Spite, man.
Guck mal, die verrecken jetzt da vorne.
Lolli.
Die sind nicht verreckt.
Ernsthaft?
Oh, Widow, Widow, Widow. Ich komm zu dir.
Sag mal, wo die ist.
Unten links, siehst du doch.
Ich seh sie net.
Jetzt seh ich sie unten links, ja.
Wow, ich hab keinen.
Das war ein böser Header.
Okay, ich geh mal runter.
Huge Mercy Place, Chat.
Bleib mal unten, solange die wieder hier unterwegs ist.
Bleib hier in der Ecke, da kann sie nicht viel machen.
Oder am besten oben in der Ecke.
Wenn er sein Schild oben hat.
Komm hoch, Hanzo, Hanzo.
Lass Schild oben, lass rein.
Lass das Schild oben.
Die Widow ist wieder am Start.
Tracer kommt links.
Irgendwo.
Oh, Reinhardt, Mann, lass das Schild vorne.
Willst du, dass die mich ficken, oder was?
Kannst du.
Hinter dir, Tracer.
Weißt du.
Die wollen einfach nicht das.
Huge.
Bin done.
Wo, wo? Ah, da.
Auf dem Standardspot.
Was war das für eine Runde?
Was ist dein Lieblings-Dass?
DPS?
Ah, du meinst DPS-Helden?
Ich spiele eigentlich relativ wenig DPS-Helden.
Wenn ich DPS-Helden spiele, eigentlich hauptsächlich Soldier.
Oder wenn es sein muss, sowas wie, ähm,
wie Reaper.
Was ich gar nicht drauf habe, einfach
erstens aus dem Grund, weil ich es bisher kaum geübt habe,
sind die ganzen Flanker.
Und irgendwie macht es mir auch nicht so großartig Spaß.
Also was mir am meisten Spaß macht,
ist eigentlich die rechte Hälfte an Helden.
Also den Tank-Teil
und den Support-Teil.
Außer Mercy jetzt mal ausgenommen,
wo mir jetzt allerdings oftmals
nichts anderes übrig bleibt, außer Mercy zu spielen.
Wir könnten da jetzt eigentlich mit Lucio
richtig fett drauf pushen.
Die Info, too many Snipers, too many
Defense-Heroes, no Tank-Heroes.
No Tank, das ist geil, oder?
No Tank, too many
Snipers, fail, ey.
Ja, ich glaube, wir
verkacken jetzt genauso wie die Gegner.
Was haben die Gegner da eigentlich getrieben?
Ja, das war auch wieder so
so ein komplett unentschlossenes Team,
was einfach nichts macht.
Da darf keiner in der Gegend rumstehen.
Aber wenn ich mich, Harpoon, wenn ich mich
für einen DPS-Hero entscheiden müsste,
so nach dem Ort im Spiel, den ich am liebsten,
dann würde ich sagen Soldier.
Aber sonst von allen Helden insgesamt eindeutig
Anna.
Mit Up schon am meisten Bock.
Leider gerade nicht so richtig dicke mit dabei.
Jetzt kommen
huge Grapple-Hook-Jump-Shots
360-Kills, oder?
360 kann ich mal probieren,
wenn ich oben bin.
Du musst aber aufpassen, stell doch Play an.
Ja.
Gut, gut, dann go.
Go for 360.
Also noch sehe ich nichts.
Die verrecken
da drüben schon auf dem Weg zum Tor.
Alter.
Ich mach mal 360.
Ich red's mal ein.
Nee, die haben ein Schild.
Wäre ein Headshot gewesen.
Moment, was geht jetzt ab?
Ich sag dir, wir verlieren das auch noch mit diesem
Gammel-Setup.
Kann gut sein.
Wenn ich mir das angucke.
Das ist definitiv das letzte Game.
Jetzt fängt Wochenende an.
Ich geh mal zu unseren McCree rein.
Wir gehen jetzt.
Oh, ich bin gehookt.
Die Symmetra hat noch keinen Porter.
Ich weiß nicht, wo du bist genau, aber...
Easy.
Easy Clap.
Nee, dann lass mal aufhören hier.
Ja, 4-1.
Das sind jetzt Games, die sind auf Brauselniveau.
Das macht auch keinen Spaß mehr.
Huge Symmetra Place.
Sick.
Absolut sick, die Place.
Oh man, ey.
So, mal kurz Punkte klotzen.
Der Chat gibt dir recht.
Aber das merkst du.
Also oftmals sind die Games am Wochenende
echt...
Es ist halt
eine Tragödie, weil die Leute nicht decayen.
Die spielen kaum.
Oder beziehungsweise spielen fast
gar nicht. Loggen nur am Wochenende ein
und dann hast du halt solche Matches.
Ich mein, du musst dir mal überlegen, das richtig
lächerliche ist ja bei der Sache, dass ich
Season 3 auf dem Main nicht mehr gespielt hab.
Aber, wenn du
Q'st, kommst du in
Highmaster-GM-Games.
Was denkt sich
dieses Matchmaking-System eigentlich
dabei? ETF.
Das sah aus
wie bei mir auf Platin.
Ja, Harpoon. Genau das Gefühl hatte ich auch gerade.
Du hättest hier mal, ich weiß nicht, Harpoon, warst du
gestern mal am Stream dabei, so geile
Games gehabt. So geile Games
gehabt. So richtig krasse Plays auch
gemacht, allesamt. Und
heute waren ja schon wieder echt so
ein Fail des Todes dabei.
So, wo sind wir jetzt eigentlich? Bei wie vielen?
Das eine Game auf Route 66,
das war ja noch so einigermaßen.
Das war mit Abstand das beste
Game, was wir heute hatten.
So rein vom
Spielablauf her.
Aber alles andere war so, naja.
Ja, das auf Route 66 war
ganz nice. Zumindest der Anfang.
Die Games, die wir gestern hatten,
die waren endgeil. Da hast du so richtig
das Gefühl gehabt, dein Team ist fett am
Start, drei Harden, jeder probiert was
und hast du nicht gesehen, das ging voll gut.
Ja, gestern waren eh, also gestern war wirklich
der Winstreak's Todes am Start und es war geil.
Warst du schon mal auf GM? Ja, in
Season 1.
Aber da war das noch nicht GM.
Da gab's doch noch diese Season 1, gab's
doch diese komischen Level noch.
Mhm. Da warst du
einfach nur eine Zahl.
Ja. Ich glaub GM
warst du irgendwie ab 70
oder so.
Ah, so in den Drehungen.
Ganz am Anfang war's geil.
Da warst du irgendwie ab,
ab 63 Top 500.
Weil's doch so gepackt war alles.
Das war schon geil.
Ja Leute, ich hoffe euch
hat's gefallen. Wir machen
den Schluss. 4 zu 3.
Leider kein flawless
Winningstream.
Season 1 gab's nur einen GM in EU.
Es gab doch in Season
1 überhaupt keine GMs. Oder bring ich das
jetzt durcheinander?
Stimmt, du hast recht.
Damals war GM noch höher als Top
500. Das war so ganz merkwürdig.
Stimmt, du hast recht.
Du hast recht. Ja, klar.
Das war am Anfang total wie
du warst Top 500 und quasi
nur ein ganz kleiner Teil von Top 500 war
wirklich Grandmaster. Das war noch
komplett umgedreht. Stimmt. Ja.
Stimmt. Stimmt.
Ich hab dir einen Link gepostet
im Chat. Ich seh
keinen Link. Ah, hier.
Weißt du was jetzt noch fehlt?
Ein Game zum Ausklinken.
Was meinst
du?
Was hast du gesagt? Ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Ich meine, ein Game zum Ausklinken fehlt
jetzt noch. Ein Game zum Ausklinken?
Äh, Yeti Hunter.
Yeti Hunter.
Hab ich noch nicht gespielt.
Das steht auch nicht mal im...
Wo ist das überhaupt? Wo kann man das überhaupt
spielen?
Arcade, ha?
Nee, das ist zu doof. Hab ich keinen Bock drauf
jetzt. Ach, ein Overworld.
Ja, ja, nee, hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich werd jetzt ein bisschen leveln in BDO.
Aber Offstream.
Muss ja irgendwann mal 60
werden. Dann muss ich dich
alleine lassen. Ja. Ist nicht mein Game.
Passt.
Dann guck ich mir jetzt noch das Video an, was dir jemand geschickt hat
im Chat. Gucken wir uns mal an.
Mal gucken, ob das
eines dieser funny Videos ist, die gar nicht funny
sind oder ob die wirklich funny sind.
Ich mute mich mal kurz im Discord.
Mhm.
Werbung. Woodface.
Werbung, geh weg.
Okay, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal zusammen an.
Ich mach Discord mal aus gerade.
Wobei, nee, ich bin gemutet. Das passt.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns das an. Also, ähm...
Video von Dinoflask.
Jeff Kaplan Upcoming
Patch
May-Christmas-Skin.
Okay, mal gucken, was da abgeht.
Das sind wohl merkwürdig zusammengeschnittene
Interviews. Schauen wir mal.
Bild, please? Man sieht doch ein Bild, oder?
Naja, klar, man sieht ein Bild.
Äh, Untertitel
machen wir noch an.
Komm, wir machen die Untertitel mal auf Deutsch.
Falls es die gibt.
So, gucken wir mal.
Baited.
I'm alone.
You can only play Symmetra.
And I really wanna try to get to Grandmaster
before the end of the next season.
So, in the 2017 patch,
we've extended the distance of the beam
at Wickelton.
She's a long-ranged beam sniper now.
It's midday every three seconds.
Um, so I had to come here
and play Shockwreck.
Aber nur ich kann diesen bestimmten Geschmack von Symmetra spielen, also das sollte für mich viel Spaß sein.
Also der große Veränderung, der das Scoreboard hat, ist, dass du jetzt sehen kannst, wer am schlechtesten auf deiner Mannschaft spielt.
Also du kannst sehr polizistisch sagen, hey Junge, vielleicht solltest du dich auf meine Lijiang-Tower schlagen und dann f***ing dich töten.
Das sollte viel besser sein.
Das ist der geilige Bock.
Die Queue-Zeiten sind wirklich lang und es gibt eine riesige Menge Salz, die aus dem kompetitiven Spiel kommt.
Aber ich möchte wirklich wieder entschuldigen, all die autistischen Mitglieder der Overwatch-Community, die über Mays saisonale legendäre Haut überrascht waren.
Du hast gesagt, wie wichtig sie war für dich.
Also bis zum Ende des letzten Jahrhunderts werden wir ganz auf DLC-Kosmetik-Rezepte arbeiten.
Also wir denken, dass ihr das genießen werdet.
Wir sind gerade aus dem Zeitraum, also machen wir Overwatch wieder großartig.
Und wir schauen uns das an.
Wir hoffen, dass wir euch bald wieder mit einem solcher Entwickler-Updates anschauen werden.
Vielen Dank, Leute.
Machen wir mal Schluss.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Und ihr wisst ja, das Übliche.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, Like, Subscribe, Comment, Donate, Follow Twitter, Twitch, Facebook, Instagram, Tumblr, Snapchat, Patreon, MySpace, StudiVZ und alles, was es so gibt.
Und macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Wir hosten jetzt den Friseur.